This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. So last year on the breakdown, we tackled The Power Broker, a book so long we needed an entire year to get through it. But it also happens to be the best book of all time. So, you know, we spent our time well. If you haven't listened to it, you definitely should check it out.
这里是《99%隐形》宪法解读播客，我是罗曼·马斯。去年在我们的解读节目中，我们聊了《权力经纪人》这本书，它实在太长了，我们花了一整年才读完。但它也碰巧是史上最好的书。所以，咱们的时间没白花。如果你还没听过，绝对应该去听听。
The series won tons of awards, including three Webbies. I'm really proud of it. And when I was thinking about what to do for our book club breakdown this year, I considered some similar books like Biographies of Fascinating People, Explorations of Urban Planning History, of American History, World History. But when I thought about what I really wanted to talk about right now in this moment, it was something totally different from the Power Broker or any sort of big weighty masterpiece of a tome. I wanted to talk about the Constitution.
这个系列获得了无数奖项，包括三个威比奖。我对此真的感到非常骄傲。当我在思考今年我们的读书会解读要做什么主题时，我想过一些类似的书籍，比如迷人人物传记、城市规划史探索、美国历史、世界历史。但当我思考此时此刻我真正想谈论的是什么时，它完全不同于《权力经纪人》或任何那种厚重的大部头杰作。我想谈谈《宪法》。
At just 7,591 words, including all 27 amendments, it's about 1% of the length of the Power Broker. But each of those words carries so much weight and history and meaning and has so much impact on our lives. And it has so many interpretations. So in many ways, breaking down the Constitution is even more daunting than any 1200 page book. But lucky for me, I happen to already have a show about constitutional law. It's called What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law, and I produce it with my neighbor,
算上全部27条修正案，它只有7591个字，长度大约是《权力经纪人》的1%。但其中的每一个字都承载着巨大的分量、历史和意义，对我们的生活产生了深远的影响。它也有着各种各样的解读。所以在很多方面，解读《宪法》甚至比任何1200页的书都要令人畏惧。但幸运的是，我碰巧已经有一个关于宪法的节目了。它叫《特朗普能教我们什么宪法课》，我和我的邻居——
the law professor Elizabeth Joe And she's going to lead us through the Constitution So for people who are unfamiliar with the other show Elizabeth, can you introduce yourself? I'm so excited to do this with you. I'm a law professor at the University of California Davis I teach courses on criminal procedure privacy But most important for our show, the introductory class to constitutional law. I also spend way too much time online and worrying about what I see there.
法学教授伊丽莎白·乔——一起制作了这个节目。她将引领我们逐字逐句地研读《宪法》。所以，对于不熟悉我们另一个节目的听众，伊丽莎白，你能自我介绍一下吗？我非常高兴能和你一起做这个节目。我是加州大学戴维斯分校的法学教授，我教刑事诉讼和隐私权等课程。但对我们节目最重要的是，我教授宪法学入门课程。我也花太多时间在网上，并为我在那儿看到的东西感到担忧。
So you're the perfect person to do this with and honestly the only person I would want to do this with. And we're going to go through the constitution article by article, maybe even breaking up an article over a couple of months if it's especially complicated or condensing some amendments as needed. We're going to really try to understand our country's founding document, but we're going to do it book club style with a different guest each month and have a fun discussion. And really anything goes. It could be all about context and history and how the constitution affects us in our present day lives, but it could also be about just the text itself, the weirdness of the text of the constitution, just anything that comes to mind when we talk about the Constitution.
所以你是做这个节目最完美的人选，老实说，也是我唯一想一起合作的人。我们将逐条逐句地研读《宪法》，如果某一条特别复杂，我们甚至可能会花几个月来拆解一条，或者根据需要合并一些修正案。我们将真正试着去理解我们国家的立国文书，但我们会以读书会的形式进行，每个月邀请不同的嘉宾，进行有趣的讨论。而且真的是畅所欲言。它可以全部关于背景、历史以及宪法如何影响我们的现实生活，也可以仅仅关于文本本身、宪法文本的奇特性，或者任何当我们谈论《宪法》时浮现脑海的想法。
We'll take a look at the genius and the many, many flaws of the Constitution. It is a short document, but let's face it, it's dry, filled with weird capitalization, odd punctuation, and no explanation whatsoever. That's right. And by the way, we're still doing what Trump can do about Con Law, where Elizabeth explains some current event to me through the lens of constitutional law.
我们将审视《宪法》的天才之处以及它许许多多的缺陷。它是一份简短的文件，但说实话，它很枯燥，充满了奇怪的大写字母、古怪的标点符号，而且没有任何解释。没错。顺便说一句，我们还在继续制作《特朗普能教我们什么宪法课》，在节目中，伊丽莎白会通过宪法学的视角向我解释一些时事。
That's gonna be the second half of each episode. So the first part will be the breakdown of some piece of the Constitution, and the second part will be about constitutional law that's impacting our lives today. Right, so we're starting, of course, from the very beginning with the preamble to the Constitution. So Roman, it's just 52 words.
这将是每一集的后半部分。所以前半部分将是对《宪法》某一部分的解读，后半部分将探讨正在影响我们今天生活的宪法。好，所以我们当然要从最开始讲起，也就是《宪法》序言。那么罗曼，它只有52个字。
So why don't you read it for us? I would love nothing more. So here we go. We the people of the United States, in order to form a more perfect union, establish justice, ensure domestic tranquility, provide for the common defense, promote the general welfare, and secure the blessings of liberty to ourselves and our posterity. Do ordain and establish this Constitution for the United States of America. Pretty good. I mean, not me. The writing was good. The reading was okay. So to talk a little bit more about the preamble, to open up our book club, we brought in journalist
你为什么不给我们读一下呢？我求之不得。那我们开始吧。我们美利坚合众国的人民，为了建立更完善的联盟，树立正义，保障国内安宁，提供共同防务，促进全民福利，并使我们自己和我们的后代得享自由的幸福，特为美利坚合众国制定并确立本宪法。相当不错。我是说，不是我写得好。写得很好，读得也还可以。为了更多地讨论序言，为我们的读书会开个好头，我们请来了记者
and writer Nicole Hannah-Jones. Nicole is an investigative reporter for the New York Times Magazine and the night chair in race and journalism at Howard University. She's perhaps best known as the creator of the 1619 Project, which posits that every aspect of America was shaped in some way by slavery and its legacy. Nicole wrote about the preamble in her opening essay for the 1619 Project, and so we thought her perspective would make for a great discussion. So we started with her reaction to those 52 words.
兼作家妮可·汉娜-琼斯。妮可是《纽约时报杂志》的调查记者，也是霍华德大学种族与新闻学奈特讲席教授。她最为人所知的身份或许是“1619项目”的创立者，该项目认为美国的方方面面都在某种程度上受到了奴隶制及其遗产的影响。妮可为“1619项目”的开篇随笔撰写了关于序言的内容，所以我们认为她的视角将带来一次极好的讨论。因此，我们从她对这52个字的反应开始聊起。
I mean, of course, you automatically think about that phrase, we the people, which are some of the most famous words that we think about when we think about this nation being constituted. And then, you know, I'm black. So my people were not considered part of we the people when those words were written. So much about that original constitution, including the original Bill of Rights, to me, are about not being included, about being excluded from what and who the founders had in mind when we call our official founders when they drafted those words. Yeah. That's definitely the first thing I think of too, is that only one of the three of us was part of that we in this discussion,
我的意思是，当然，你会自动想起那个词组——“我们人民”，当我们想到这个国家是如何建立的时，这是我们脑海中最著名的词汇之一。然后，你知道的，我是黑人。所以当这些字被写下来时，我的人民并没有被视为“我们人民”的一部分。在我看来，关于最初的那部宪法，包括最初的《权利法案》，很大程度上都关乎“未被纳入”，关乎当我们的官方奠基人在起草这些字时，他们心中所想的“什么”和“谁”将我们排除在外。是的。这绝对也是我首先想到的事情，即在这个讨论中，我们三个人里只有一个人属于那个“我们”，
which is a glaring issue with the preamble to the Constitution, for sure. So I'm gonna sort of ask Elizabeth here, in terms of the preamble, what is the preamble trying to do here, sort of like in terms of the legal document of the Constitution? Sure. It's really short.
这绝对是《宪法》序言中一个显而易见的问题。所以我在这里要问伊丽莎白，就序言而言，序言在这里试图做些什么，比如说从《宪法》作为法律文件的角度来看？当然。它真的很短。
It comes at the beginning of the original Constitution, of course, and it actually does a lot in that one sentence. First, it tells us where the power to enact the Constitution comes from, and it says, we the people, as we've discussed. It doesn't come from the states or from, you know, from the king or anything like that. So it comes from the people directly. And then second, it identifies the six very lofty goals
它当然出现在最初《宪法》的开篇，而且它在那短短的一句话里其实做了很多事情。首先，它告诉我们制定《宪法》的权力从何而来，正如我们所讨论的，它说的是“我们人民”。它不是来自各州，也不是来自国王之类的人。所以它直接来自于人民。其次，它确定了六个非常崇高的目标
of the Constitution, things like ensuring domestic tranquility, establishing justice, although of course, it doesn't define what any of those things mean. And then finally, it shows us the intent of the framers when it says that this is for ourselves and posterity. In other words, this is not a document, the original constitution meant to be a kind of temporary solution of the 18th century. It's meant to be a document that lasts for generations. And it has. I mean, this is the longest in use written constitution that
——比如确保国内安宁、建立正义，尽管当然，它并没有定义这些词中的任何一个具体意味着什么。最后，它通过说明这是“为了我们自己和我们的后代”向我们展示了制定者的意图。换句话说，这不是一份最初的宪法意图成为18世纪某种临时解决方案的文件。它旨在成为一份能够历经数代人传承的文件。它也确实做到了。我的意思是，这是现存使用时间最长的成文宪法，
exists, which is kind of stunning. That's right. You know, when you look at the preamble, the entirety, not just, you know, my focus on we the people, um, and then thinking about this, you know, the idea that it is the kind of longest, still-in-use constitution. As a writer, I also can't help but just think about how remarkable it is and what it must be like to try to sit down and put words on paper um, to create kind of the parameters of this new nation and this aspirations, like just to try to constitute a new nation in and of itself. It's such a bold and audacious act.
这简直令人震惊。没错。你知道，当你审视序言的全部内容时，不仅仅是——你知道的——我所关注的“我们人民”，然后考虑到这一点，你知道，它作为一种“仍在使用的历时最长的宪法”的概念。作为一名作家，我也情不自禁地去想，这是多么的非凡，去尝试坐下来把文字写在纸上会是什么感觉，为了建立这个新国家的种种参数和愿景，仅仅是试着去组建一个新国家本身。这是一种如此大胆和果敢的行为。
And then to say, how do we write the very opening words, uh, to the document that's going to hold and this whole thing together, that's going to guide this thing. And so it's both very, uh very specific, but also necessarily vague. And I'm sure we'll get into all the tensions that vagueness will bring forth, but you also have to be. So even thinking of we the people, like we know who we the people was referring to then, but it's also so it allows for so much expansion at the same time. Because now we the people is, it is me, it is Elizabeth, right?
然后还要考虑，我们如何为这份将把这一切凝聚在一起、并将指引这个国家的文件写下最开头的词句？所以它既非常具体，但又不可避免地有些含糊。我确信我们会深入探讨这种含糊性所带来的种种张力，但你也必须如此。所以即使想想“我们人民”，就像我们知道那时“我们人民”指的是谁，但它同时也允许在同时进行如此巨大的扩展。因为现在的“我们人民”，它是我，它是伊丽莎白，对吧？
It is women. It is people who descended from slavery. It is people who weren't even considered as having the right to have citizenship at that time. And so it's deeply flawed as the founders were. It is kind of a remarkable thing to be able to put this vision out into the world and both say, you know, we are going to establish justice. And it tells you what was most important to them as they are deciding to break off, you know, as they had broken off from the most powerful nation in the world at the time and what were their values, but also what
它是女性。它是奴隶制的后代。它是那些在当时甚至不被认为有权拥有公民身份的人。因此，尽管奠基人们有着种种缺陷，这仍然是一件非凡的事情，能够将这种愿景展现于世人面前，并且一方面说，你知道的，“我们要树立正义”。它告诉了你当他们决定分道扬镳时——你知道的，就像他们当时与世界上最强大的国家分道扬镳时——什么对他们最重要，他们的价值观是什么，但同时也关乎他们担心的是什么？所以无论如何，我只是在想，当我们看到所有这些最高法院的裁决出炉、而他们正在解释这份文件时，试图创造出能够经受几个世纪考验、既能给你界限又能让你拥有如此广泛解释的东西，这是一项多么不可能完成的工作。
were they worried about? So anyway, I just was thinking about just, as we see all of these Supreme Court rulings coming down and they are interpreting this document, what an impossible job it is to try to create something that can withstand centuries, that can both give you boundary, but also allow you to have this much broader interpretation. So when you read We the People in that context,
所以当你在这个语境下阅读“我们人民”时，
do you see the intent of open interpretation over generations in those words, or do you think this is partly happy accident? Elizabeth Stringer Oh, I'm actually really curious what you think, Elizabeth, as a constitutional scholar. I don't know. I can only look at – so part of me says, absolutely, they did not intend someone like myself to be included in the protections of this constitutional document.
你是否从这些字眼背后看到了历经数代人进行开放式解释的意图，还是你认为这部分只是一场幸存的意外？伊丽莎白·斯特林：哦，作为一名宪法学者，我其实真的很想知道你的看法，伊丽莎白。我不知道。我只能这样看——一部分的我认为，绝对的，他们绝没有意图让像我这样的人被包含在这个宪法文件的保护之内。
We know that because we can look at what else they said in the Constitution. But on the other hand, I also know that the drafters were complex and complicated men who even around the issue of slavery were grappling with the hypocrisy of what they were doing and allowing, were grappling with whether or not abolition would be possible, who understood evolution would come one day. And so I can't say that I believe they really intended it to be read as broadly as we do now, but I think they certainly expected that one day it would be more inclusive than it was when they wrote those words. And I do think that so much of that, you know, even the fact that they don't put the word slavery or slave in the document, is they are looking to how they will be seen
我们知道这一点，因为我们可以看看他们在宪法中还说了什么。但另一方面，我也知道，起草者们是复杂而纠结的人，他们甚至在奴隶制问题上也在与他们正在做的事情和允许的事情的虚伪性作斗争，在权衡废奴是否可能，他们明白演变总有一天会到来。所以我不能说我相信他们真的打算让它像我们今天这样被广泛解读，但我认为他们肯定预料到，总有一天它会比他们写下这些字时更具包容性。而且我确实认为，这其中的很大一部分，你知道的，甚至连他们在文件中没有写下“奴隶制”或“奴隶”这个词的事实，都表明他们正在展望自己将如何被后人看待。
one day. And as they are creating this document for posterity, they're clearly thinking about the future and how they will be judged against this document and this nation that they founded against this document. So, yeah, maybe I think they allowed for some room, some expansion, but clearly not the way we have now interpreted. I don't think so. That sort of tension is like internal in the preamble itself, right? We were talking both about the intent of the people who made it, thinking about a posterity they couldn't possibly imagine, right? What like five, ten generations later, what would the country look like? And then thinking to where we are now, Nicole, you and I look at we the people
当他们为后代创建这份文件时，他们显然在考虑未来，考虑他们将如何根据这份文件以及他们以这份文件为基础建立的国家来接受审判。所以，是的，也许我认为他们留出了一些空间，一些扩展的空间，但显然不是我们现在所解释的那种方式。我不认为是这样。这种张力就像是序言本身内部固有的，对吧？我们讨论的是制定者的意图，考虑他们根本无法想象的后代，对吧？比如五代、十代之后，这个国家会是什么样子？然后想想我们现在的处境，妮可，你和我看着“我们人民”，
and we see ourselves, right? And that's kind of the remarkable genius of the document, as flawed as it is, and as flawed as its interpretations have been. And so I think part of what's hopeful for me anyway, and perhaps for you, I'd love to hear your thoughts on it, is that it's that kind of tense, ambiguous,
我们看到了我们自己，对吧？这正是这份文件非凡的天才之处，尽管它有种种缺陷，其种种解释也有种种缺陷。所以我认为对我而言充满希望的一部分，以及也许对你而言也是如此——我很想听听你的想法——正是那种紧张、模棱两可、
open-endedness that has, I think, sustained the Constitution and why it's still with us today when so many other countries around the world, they've gone through many iterations of a founding document. Yeah, I mean, you know, the funny thing about the Constitution is many authors. The author of the preamble is mostly credited to this fellow named Governor Morris, who if you want your kid to have a leg up on life, name him Governor, you know, like that's a
开放的特性，我认为这正是维系《宪法》的原因，也是为什么时至今日它依然陪伴着我们，而世界上许多其他国家的建国文件却已经经历了好几次迭代。是的，我的意思是，你知道的，《宪法》有趣的地方在于它有很多作者。序言的作者主要归功于一个叫古弗尼尔·莫里斯（Gouverneur Morris）的家伙，如果你想让你的孩子在人生中占得先机，就给他起名叫“古弗尼尔（Governor，意为总督）”，你知道的，这倒是个不错的选择。
good way to go. But you know, I think you can kind of tell in, you know, he was an abolitionist. You know, like I think you can kind of read some of that in there, even though like the rest of the document placates, you know, the practice. And I don't know, I kind of feel it, but I also feel a strange tension in it.
但你知道，我想你能从他的经历中看出来，他是个废奴主义者。你知道的，我觉得你可以在字里行间读出一些那种意味，尽管文件的其余部分在安抚这种制度。我不知道，我能感觉得到，但我在其中也感到了一种奇怪的张力。
And it's, I think it's fascinating. It's also just like, you know, it's so soaring as a beginning, like as a, you know, if we're reading this just as text, the plot of the Constitution like comes to a screeching halt the next paragraph. I mean, it just gets real boring really fast.
这让我觉得太迷人了。它同时就像是，你知道的，作为一个开端它是如此高亢，就像如果我们将此仅仅作为文本来阅读，《宪法》的情节在下一段就来了个急刹车。我的意思是，它很快就变得非常无聊。
And this moment here is this moment where it really, the openness of it all is, I think is is evident in its text, and I think it's really fascinating. But speaking of the stuff that follows, the Constitution has always been full of contradictions, especially when it comes to slavery and civil rights. And so on July 4th, 1854, the abolitionist William Lord Garrison burned the Constitution at a public rally, saying that it was a covenant with death and an agreement with hell in the way that it countenanced and even enshrined slavery.
而这里的这个时刻，正是那种完全的开放性在文本中显而易见的时刻，我认为这真的非常迷人。但说到接下来的内容，《宪法》一直充满着矛盾，尤其是在奴隶制和民权方面。因此，在1854年7月4日，废奴主义者威廉·劳埃德·加里森（William Lloyd Garrison）在一次公开集会上焚烧了《宪法》，称它是“与死亡的盟约，与地狱的协议”，因为它纵容甚至奉奴隶制为圭臬。
And at the same time, Frederick Douglass was arguing kind of the opposite, saying that the Constitution and particularly the Preamble, you know, should be embraced, you know, rhetorically and use it as a guiding light towards the abolition of slavery, even with its flaws and contradictions. So when you hear the preamble, do you feel those different sentiments? Like which sentiment feels more resonant at any given moment?
与此同时，弗雷德里克·道格拉斯（Frederick Douglass）则辩称了完全相反的观点，他认为《宪法》，尤其是序言，（你知道的）应该在修辞上被拥抱，并将其作为废除奴隶制的指路明灯，哪怕它存在缺陷和矛盾。所以当你听到序言时，你是否能感受到那些不同的情绪？就像在任何特定的时刻，哪种情绪更能引发共鸣？
Well, one, I think we should be clear that originally Frederick Douglass considered the Constitution a pro-slavery document. Yes. And in fact, he splits with Garrison on this later, and he announces a change of opinion. And I think what happens, I mean, this is my interpretation, is he realizes it's not actually very effective. If you're trying to appeal to the morality of Americans, of white Americans,
嗯，首先，我认为我们应该搞清楚，最初弗雷德里克·道格拉斯认为《宪法》是一份支持奴隶制的文件。是的。事实上，他后来在这点上与加里森分道扬镳，并宣布改变了自己的看法。我认为发生的事情是——我的理解是——他意识到这实际上并没有那么有效。如果你试图诉诸美国人、白人美国人的道德，
in saying that slavery is wrong, it was a much greater rhetorical argument to say actually your own constitution mandates that slavery must end, that this is a constitution for a free people. And so I think that that's very true. Yeah. We have come to, of course, now interpret this document
说奴隶制是错误的，那么运用这样一种修辞论点——即实际上你们自己的宪法就强制要求奴隶制必须结束，这是一部为自由人民制定的宪法——要强有力得多。所以我认为这是非常真实的。是的。我们现在当然已经将这份文件解释为一份自由文件，但它当时并不是。我们在他们起草文件的过程中，就知道关于奴隶制及其局限性的争论。我们知道“五分之三妥协”是为了让蓄奴阶层受益。但我也认为，在很大程度上，你知道的，对黑人同胞而言，自由文件其实是《独立宣言》。正是黑人将《独立宣言》变成了一份自由文件。当然，《独立宣言》是一份分裂文件。但黑人阅读了——你知道的——“我们认为这些真理不言而喻：人人生而平等，造物者赋予他们若干不可剥夺的权利”，并说，哦，这适用于我们。这就像我们以及道格拉斯最终阅读《宪法》的方式一样：你们的意思是维持白人男性的财产利益，许多起草者本人就从事着动产奴隶制，白人男性的财产，许多起草者本人就从事着动产奴隶制，男性的财产。
as a liberty document, but it was not. We know the arguments over slavery and its limitations as they are drafting the document. We know that the three-fifths compromise goes to benefit the slave-holding class. But I also think much the way that, you know, really for black folks, the Liberty document is the declaration of independence. And it's black people who turn the declaration into a liberty document. Of course, the declaration is a succession document. But black folks read, you know, we hold these truths
但我们将其解读为对自由的要求。这正是美国黑人在这片土地上一直扮演的角色：你们拥有崇高的概念，我们必须努力让这个概念变为现实。
to be self-evident that all men are created equal and dialed by the creator of the unalienable rights as saying, oh, this applies to us. And that's much the way that we, and Douglas ends up reading the constitution is you meant this to sustain the property interests of white men, many of the drafters being themselves
你提到道格拉斯的乐观情绪，特别是关于序言的乐观情绪，这太有趣了，因为他关于序言的著名演讲之一，当然是对《斯科特诉桑福德案》（Dred Scott）的直接回应。也许我们应该为听众概括一下什么是《斯科特诉桑福德案》。这是1857年最高法院臭名昭著的判决，黑奴德雷德·斯科特（Dred Scott）起诉要求获得自由，理由是他曾在奴隶制非法的自由领土上居住过。尽管他最初的诉求是关于承认其自由身份的依据，但当他的案子闹到最高法院时，其实只剩下一个问题：德雷德·斯科特是否被视为美利坚合众国公民。
engaged in chat of slavery, the property white men, many of the drafters being themselves engaged in chattel slavery, the property of men. But we read it as demanding liberty. And this has been the role that Black Americans have always played in this country is you have the lofty concept. We have to try to make that concept manifest. It's so interesting that you mention Douglas's optimism, particularly about the preamble, because one of his famous speeches, of course, about the preamble
而美国最高法院说：不。在首席大法官罗杰·托尼（Roger Taney）的一份意见书中，托尼说，在德雷德·斯科特不能被视为公民的种种理由或主张中，看看序言吧。《宪法》的序言确实有我们一直提到的那些宽泛的词语：“我们人民”，黑人美国人能成为那个政治共同体的一部分吗？而托尼的意见书本质上说的是：
is in direct reaction to Dred Scott. Maybe we should recap for our listeners what Dred Scott is. This is the infamous 1857 Supreme Court decision in which Dred Scott, an enslaved man, sued for his freedom on the basis that he had lived in a free territory where slavery was illegal. And although his original claim was about the basis for recognizing his free status, by the time his case goes up to the Supreme Court, it's really only one question whether or not Dred Scott is considered a citizen of the United States.
不，我们不能字面理解序言。我们不能字面理解它。我们必须看到，事实上，《宪法》提到了奴隶制这一制度，提到了被奴役的人，因此黑人美国人就是他所称的“劣等阶级的人”。而事实上，我很好奇妮可你对此怎么看，因为你在“1619项目”的随笔中探讨过，《斯科特诉桑福德案》正是我们今天看到的根深蒂固的种族主义的根源。我很想知道，你能多谈谈这种历史遗产对人们意味着什么吗？
And the United States Supreme Court said no. In an opinion by Chief Justice Roger Taney, Taney says that among the claims or among the reasons why Dred Scott can't be considered a citizen, he says, look at the preamble. The Constitution's preamble does have these broad words that we've been referring to. We the people, could black Americans be part of that political community? And essentially what Taney's opinion says is,
是的，我的意思是，你知道的，当我们有一位威胁要终结出生公民权的总统时，谈论《斯科特诉桑福德案》是多么应景的时刻啊。通常我们会说他没有权力这么做。我们有一个最高法院，目前还不清楚它会被解释为他是否有权这么做。当他威胁要剥夺那些政治观点不合他心意的人的公民权时。所以我一直在想，当然，当你阅读《斯科特诉桑福德案》时，不仅该裁决是在说黑人属于劣等种族，它是在说黑人属于奴隶种族，我们天生注定的地位就是被奴役和可被奴役的，因此要沦为财产，
no, we can't take the preamble literally. We don't take it literally. We have to see that in fact, the Constitution refers to the institution of slavery, refers to enslaved people, and therefore black Americans are what he calls people of an inferior order. And that actually, I'm curious to hear Nicole what you think of this because you discussed in your 1619 Project Essay that Dred Scott is kind of the root of the endemic racism that we see today. And I'm curious, could you say more about what that legacy means for folks?
并且永远不能成为“我们人民”的一部分，因为我们甚至都不是人。所以在我看来，当然，这背后的根基远在那个裁决之前就已经开始了，但在最高法院——这个被指派去解释宪法及其保护的最高司法机构——内部，居然有法官争辩说黑人、非洲后代存在于这份文件的保护范围之外，那么这当然就在我们的体制中——不仅是我们的法律系统，还包括我们的政治系统和社会系统——为这样一种观念进行了辩护和法典化：奴隶制不是一种处境，对吧？这当然是我思考它的方式，也是我们的许多奠基人坦率地认为黑人是人类、但我们可以处于被奴役处境的方式。而他（托尼）所说的是，这不是一种处境。它是天生的。当奴隶是天生的。这就是你是谁。但这很难动摇，关于黑人这种与生俱来的劣等性的许多信念——即我们就是低人一等，这与我们的祖先曾被奴役毫无关系，而是因为我们低人一等，所以我们的祖先才被奴役。我们显然仍在与这些想法作斗争。甚至连出生公民权这样神圣不可侵犯的事情也一样，因为人们的信念是，它是基于错误的条款产生的，因为黑人不应该自动获得公民权，因此许多其他人也同样不应该。
Yeah, I mean, you know, what a time to be talking about Dred Scott when we have a president who is threatening to end birthright citizenship and what normally we would say he doesn't have the power to do that. We have a Supreme Court where it's not clear whether it will be interpreted as whether he does have the power to do that. And when he's threatening to strip citizenship from people whose political views he doesn't like. So I have thought about, of course, when you read Dred Scott, it's not only that the ruling is saying black people are of an inferior race, they're saying that black people are of a slave race, that our natural innate status is to be enslaved and enslaveable and therefore to be property
是的。伊丽莎白，你提到过，序言在《斯科特诉桑福德案》中被援引，我们谈到过多年来在宪法诉讼中被援引的许多条款。
and to never be part of we the people because we're not even people. And so to me, of course, the foundations of that began much, much earlier before that ruling, but to have the highest court in the land who's charged with interpreting the constitution and its protections to argue that black people, people who descend from Africa exist outside of the protections of this document, then of course that then justifies and codifies within our, not just our legal system,
你知道，建立条款和平等保护条款。在宪法诉讼中，序言被使用的频率有多高，在某种程度上被提及的频率有多高？嗯，它今天在顺带提及时被使用，作为一种试图说“好吧，我们人民，我们为了修辞目的谈论一个更完善的联盟”的方式，但它其实很快就消亡了。这是因为1905年一个名为“雅各布森诉马萨诸塞州案”（Jacobson v. Massachusetts）的案件。
but in our political systems and our social systems, this idea that slavery is not a condition, right? Which is of course the way that I think about it. And that many of our founders frankly, who understood that black people were human beings, but that we can have the condition of being enslaved. What he's saying is it's not a condition. It is innate. Being a slave is innate. It is who you are. But that has been hard to shake that so much of the beliefs about this kind of inherent inferiority of Black people, that we are just a lesser people and it has nothing to do with the fact that our ancestors were enslaved, that it was because we were lesser that our ancestors were enslaved. We're clearly still grappling with those ideas. Even something is sacrosanct as birthright citizenship, because the belief is it was brought about
所以为什么我不简单介绍一下这个案子呢？“雅各布森诉马萨诸塞州案”涉及对一项允许强制接种疫苗的马萨诸塞州法律的法律挑战。雅各布森，亨利·雅各布森（Henry Jacobson）是一个说“我不希望这种事发生在我身上”的人。1901年曾爆发过天花疫情，剑桥市要求每个人都接种天花疫苗。你可以把亨利·雅各布森看作是某种最初的反疫苗人士。他说，你怎么知道这些东西有效？
on faulty terms because black people should not have gotten automatic citizenship, and therefore a lot of other people should not have as well. Yeah. Elizabeth, you mentioned that sort of like, the preamble is sort of invoked in Dred Scott, and we've talked about over the years, lots of clauses that have been invoked in constitutional law.
它们可能会杀人。没有任何理由表明它们在对抗天花方面是有效的。所以他在州法院败诉了，但他的案子最终上诉到了美国最高法院。他的论点之一是，这种州法律违反了他在序言之下的权利。而在1905年，最高法院以一段非常短的段落裁决：
You know, the establishment clause and the equal protection clause. How often is the preamble used in constitutional law pointed to in some way? Well, it's used today in passing as a way of trying to say, well, we the people, we talk about a more perfect union for rhetorical purposes, but it died a pretty quick death actually. And that's because of a case from 1905 called Jacobson versus Massachusetts.
不，你在序言之下没有任何权利。任何人都没有权利。没有任何权力和权利源自序言。事情就到此为止。所以在1905年之后，我们看到的情况是，真的没有人再给予它太多关注，无论是在法学研究方面，还是作为法庭上的辩护理由，律师们都不会为了推进案件而引用序言，
So why don't I say a little bit about that, right? The case of Jacobson versus Massachusetts involved a legal challenge to a Massachusetts law that permitted the use of mandatory vaccinations. And Jacobson, Henry Jacobson was a fellow who said, I don't want that to happen to me. There had been a smallpox outbreak in 1901, and the city of Cambridge required everyone to get vaccinations against smallpox. You can think of Henry Jacobson as kind of the original anti-vaxxer. He says, well, how do you know these are effective?
因为雅各布森案的缘故。这太迷人了。显而易见，正如回响所言，比如“树立正义”在第四到第八修正案中得到了很多处理。它延伸到了具体解决这些问题的方式中。但我们在一些条款以及修正案的开篇条款中倾注了大量含义。
They might kill people. There's no reason to show that they're effective in combating smallpox. So he lost in the state courts, but his case eventually goes up to the United States Supreme Court. And one of his arguments was that such a state law violated his rights under the preamble. And in 1905, the Supreme Court decided,
而完全驳回宪法开篇的这种试探，你知道的，就赋予权利而言，这很有趣。我想它只是一种理想的声明，我不知道。我想是吧。从某种意义上说，这太糟了，因为它有许多我们之前讨论过的开放式短语，这些短语确实可以成为社会中许多变革、积极变革的基础。但法院在20世纪初基本上就裁定：不，
in a very short paragraph, no, you don't have rights under the preamble. Nobody has rights. There are no powers or rights that arise from the preamble. And that was the end of that. And so what we have after 1905 is really, no one really pays that much attention in terms of legal scholarship or, you know, as an argument in court, lawyers don't refer to the preamble
如果你想做出那种改变，你必须在宪法的其他地方寻找依据。有趣。是的，从来不知道这一点。太迷人了。这也是个疫苗案，这同样令人着迷。每当你研究历史时，你就会意识到我们从未真正解决过大多数问题。这完全是真的。嗯，这某种程度上具有讽刺意味，对吧？那就是：我们到底希望从序言中得到什么？你知道，我们讨论了这样一个事实：在1857年，这被当作德雷德·斯科特推进其论点的来源而遭到驳回。但如果你仔细想想，你知道，我想每个人今天都会说《斯科特诉桑福德案》是一个糟糕透顶的案件。
as a way of advancing cases because of the Jacobson case. That's fascinating. Obviously, as Echo is like, establishing justice is handled a lot in the Fourth through the Eighth Amendment, for example. It casts forward into ways that they're specifically addressed. But we put a lot of meaning into the clauses and opening clauses of amendments, for example.
德雷德·斯科特本该赢的。法院本该承认他是美利坚合众国公民。你知道的，序言本该是赋予或承认他权利的理由之一。但这与像雅各布森这样的人的想法有些格格不入，对吧？因为如果序言曾是权利的来源，好吧，也许这位20世纪初的反疫苗人士就会赢得他的官司，对吧？
And it's interesting to dismiss this opening sort of gambit for the Constitution completely, you know, like in terms of conferring rights at all. It's just a statement of ideals, I guess. I don't know. I guess so. I mean, in a way, it's too bad because it has a lot of these open-ended phrases, as we were talking about earlier, that really could be the basis for a lot of change, positive change in society. But the court essentially decided very early in the 20th century, nope,
这在某种程度上向我们展示了说“这些是我们应该转向的来源，或是应该倡导法院作为推进法律、承认个人权利的途径来使用的来源”的复杂性。这在某种程度上表明了这些问题会有多么复杂。嗯，就《宪法》本身的性质而言，我的意思是，妮可，在你最近的随笔中，你谈到了这样一个事实：宪法并没有改变，
you have to look elsewhere in the Constitution if you want to make those kinds of changes. Interesting. Yeah, never knew that. Fascinating. Also fascinating that it would be a vaccine case. He just, always when you study history, you realize we never resolve most issues. It's totally true. Well, that's kind of an irony, right? And that is, what do we really want from the preamble? You know, we talk about the fact that this is, you know, dismissed as a source for Dred Scott to advance his arguments in 1857. But if you think about it, you know, I think everybody today would say Dred Scott is a
特朗普却试图扭转20世纪民权的许多进展。就像，《宪法》根本没有变。改变的是政治意愿。你能谈谈这个吗？就像，拥有这样一件东西意味着什么——我不知道，当我开始这个每月与伊丽莎白谈话的项目时，它是关于把《宪法》当作保护我的毯子，因为我担心这个国家。
terrible case. Dred Scott should have won. The court should have recognized him as a citizen of the United States. You know, the preamble should have been one of the reasons to confer or to recognize rights for him. But that sits uncomfortably with this idea of a guy like Jacobson, right? Because if the preamble had been a source of rights, well, maybe this early 20th century anti-vaxxer would have won his case, right?
然后我意识到，有一段时间这让人感到安慰，但后来我只是意识到规则不如以前那么重要了。现在感觉这就是这个国家目前的氛围，也是近期裁决所呈现的样子。所以，当《宪法》没有改变，并且它充满了矛盾，而真正推动这些事情四处变化的只是政治意愿时，
And that kind of shows us the complication of saying early 20th century anti-vaxxer would have won his case, right? And that kind of shows us the complication of saying these are sources that we should turn to or advocate that the court should use as a way of advancing the law of recognizing individuals' rights. That kind of shows how complicated these issues can be. Well, in the nature of the Constitution itself, I mean, in your most recent essay, Nicole, like you talk about the fact that the Constitution didn't
《宪法》在你的世界观以及它是如何运作的思考中，究竟处于什么位置？所以，你知道，再次强调，作为在美国被奴役的人的后代，《宪法》对我来说当然一直是一份非常复杂的文件。我不知道我是否曾觉得《宪法》是一条受保护的毯子。你知道，再次强调，
change for Trump to attempt to roll back many of the advances of civil rights of the 20th century. Like, the Constitution didn't change at all. It was political will that changed. Can you talk about that? Like, what does it mean to have this thing that, I don't know, when I started this project of talking to Elizabeth every month, it was about using the Constitution as this blanket to protect me because I was worried about the country.
我们最初只是作为财产被纳入其中的。因此，当你从未需要它时，《宪法》的保护对你而言是最隐形的。当你的权利是与生俱来的时，你会觉得你拥有这种保护，因为我从来不需要真正为之奋斗。但对美国黑人和许多其他被边缘化的群体来说，这是一场持续不断的斗争。所以对我来说，我的意思是，《宪法》对我而言是从“重建修正案”开始的。第13、第14和第15修正案被认为是第二次建国或带来了第二次建国。
And then I realized that for a while that felt comforting, but then it's just like I realized that the rules don't matter as much as they once did. It just feels like that's the vibe of the country right now and sort of what the recent rulings are like. So like, when the constitution doesn't change and it's full of contradictions and it's really just political will that moves these things around,
这就是《宪法》真正开始的地方。这种平等保护的概念是一件很了不起的事情，能够被写入你的宪法中。然而，其实际意义以及其中的现实情况，往往被留给了九个未经选举的白人男性，由他们来决定这对我们其他人意味着什么。直到最近，在绝大多数美国历史中，都是九个未经选举的白人男性。因此，如果权利无法得到执行，或者如果没有被执行，它们就是毫无意义的。我们确实有一部旨在保护少数群体权利的宪法，无论这个少数群体可能是谁。
where does the constitution sit inside of your thinking about the world and how it is. So, you know, again, as a descendant of people who were enslaved in the United States, the Constitution, of course, has always been very complicated document for me. I don't know that I have ever felt that the Constitution was a protected blanket. You know, again,
我认为这也是它能持续这么久的部分原因，因为它确实具备这一点。但同样，仅仅因为它存在，并不意味着它得到了执行。所以我认为它总是提供这样一种希望，对吧？即它并非不可能。但它必须存在于这样一个国家中，在这里，你拥有的权利可以由以下因素决定：你知道的，你是否能拉拢足够多的人同意你理应拥有这些权利，并且你必须不断地生活在这样一种状态中——如果多数派或投票多数派决定你不应该拥有，
we were only included as property originally. And so the protection of the Constitution to me is most invisible when you've never needed it. When your rights are innate, it feels like you have the protection because I've never had to actually fight for them. But for black Americans and many other marginalized groups, there's been a constant struggle. And so, to me, I mean, the Constitution begins for me with the Reconstruction Amendments. The 13th and 14th and 15th Amendments are considered like second founding or bringing about the second founding.
那么你就不会拥有。这也是《宪法》所允许的。但我也认为，要创造出一部在任何你认为它应该发挥作用的方式上都能永远发挥作用的宪法，是一件不可能完成的任务。是的。所以妮可，我不得不问你，那么今天，你对利用法院——也许不是最高法院——来强制执行平等和正义的规范、并维持我们在民权时代以来所看到的这种进展有多乐观？基于你一直在撰写和谈论的一切。
This is when the Constitution starts. And this idea of equal protection is an amazing thing to have placed in your constitution. And yet it's so often what that means in the reality of that has been left to nine unelected white men who get to decide what that means for the rest of us. And until very recently, nine un-elected white men for most of the history of this country. And so rights are meaningless if they can't be enforced or if they are not enforced. And we do have a constitution that is supposed to protect the rights of minority groups, whatever that minority may be.
是的，我的意思是，你知道，再次强调，我是在跟一位宪法学者说话，而我不是。但很明显，只要看看下级法院一直在做出的裁决，反对那些在我看来是公然违宪的行为，法院在政府的三权分立中一直是最能坚守阵地、并且在我看来在很大程度上一直以适当的角色在制衡体系中发挥作用的。但当然，问题在于拥有最终发言权的最高法院却没有这么做。因此，针对诸如出生公民权或跨性别权利等事情的禁令……我的意思是，任何数量的案件，我刚才还在读里根任命的法官的庭审裁决，他称特朗普的DEI（多元、公平、包容）裁决是公然的歧视。我想他在发布意见书之前在庭审裁决中说过，在他多年的法官生涯中——现在这是一位里根任命的法官——在他多年的法官生涯中，在他多年的法官生涯中，他从未见过来自联邦政府如此公然的歧视。所以你会觉得，哇，好吧。但接着你会想，如果这个案子被上诉，
And I think that's part of the reason it has lasted so long is it does actually have that. But again, just because it exists doesn't mean that there is an enforcement of that. So I think it always provides this hope, right? That it is not impossible. But there's something to it having to exist in a country where the rights you have can be determined by, you know, whether or not you can get enough people to agree that you should have those rights and to constantly have to exist in a state of if the majority or the voting majority decides you shouldn't,
这很可能会发生，那么你将面临一个在我看来正与该法院浩瀚历史保持一致做出裁决的最高法院。这就是另一回事了。我认为人们倾向于将最高法院视为“沃伦法院”。这正是我们在美国如何总结最高法院过去的某种方式。而我觉得：不，在绝大多数美国历史中，法院都在反对保护少数群体的权利。它极少为边缘化人群扩大权利。所以这就是我的恐惧——是的，我认为下级法院在坚守我们的宪法权利底线方面做得非常出色。但如果要让我设想我们该如何书写这段历史，在20或30年后，这段时期必将被视为美国历史上最糟糕、最倒退的法院之一。以我这个外行人的观点来看，我看不出我们还能如何看待它。是的。所以，我们讨论了《宪法》作为权利最后防线、作为法律文件的不足之处。作为象征性的，或者至少，我不知道，在不同时刻象征性文件中最好的部分，我想。这让我有点想起
then you won't. And that is also what the Constitution allows. But it's also an impossible thing to create, I think, a Constitution that will always work in whatever way you think it should work. Yeah. Yeah. So Nicole, I have to ask you then today, how optimistic are you about the use of courts, maybe not the Supreme Court, the use of courts
那么你就不会。这也是宪法所允许的。但我认为，制定一部在任何你希望它发挥作用的方式下都能始终起作用的宪法，也是一件不可能的事情。是的。是的。所以妮可，我今天不得不问你，你对利用法院（也许不是最高法院，而是利用法院）来维护平等和公正的规范，以及维持民权运动以来我们所看到的这种进步有多乐观？
to try and enforce norms of equality and justice and kind of maintaining that progress that we've seen since the Civil Rights era, based on everything you've been writing and speaking about. Yeah, I mean, you know, again, I'm speaking to a constitutional scholar here and I am not. But obviously, just looking at the way that the lower courts have been ruling against what to me are some pretty blatantly unconstitutional actions, the courts have held out of the three branches of government, the courts have held the most and have actually, to me, been largely serving in their appropriate role
根据你所写和所讲的一切，试图去执行平等和公正的规范，并保持自民权时代以来我们所看到的进步。是的，我的意思是，你知道，再次强调，我是在跟一位宪法学者对话，而我不是。但很明显，看看下级法院的裁决方式，他们反对在我看来是一些相当公然违宪的行为，在政府的三个分支中，法院坚持得最多，而且对我来说，在很大程度上一直在分权与制衡体系中扮演着其应有的角色。
in the systems of checks and balances. But of course, the issue is the highest court that has the final say is not. So these injunctions against things like birthright citizenship or trans rights. I mean, any number of cases, I was just reading the bench ruling from the Reagan appointee who called Trump's DEI rulings blatantly discriminatory. I think he said in his bench ruling before he released his opinion that in all his years on the court, now this is a Reagan appointee, that in all his years on the court, now this is a Reagan appointing, that in all his years on the court, he had never seen such blatant discrimination from the federal government. And so you're like, wow, okay. But then you're like, if that case is appealed,
但当然，问题是拥有最终发言权的最高法院却不是这样。因此，这些针对诸如出生公民权或跨性别权益等事务的禁令。我是说，有各种各样的案件，我刚刚读到一位里根任命的法官的当庭裁决，他称特朗普的DEI（多元、公平、包容）裁决是公然歧视。我想他在发布意见之前的当庭裁决中说，在他法官生涯的这些年里——这可是一位里根任命的法官——在他法官生涯的这些年里，他从未见过来自联邦政府如此公然的歧视。所以你会觉得，哇，好吧。但接着你会想，如果这个案件被上诉，
which it probably will be, then you're going to go up to a Supreme Court that to me is ruling in line with the vast history of the court. And this is the other thing. I think people tend to think about the Supreme Court as the Warrant Court. That's kind of how we encapsulate what the Supreme Court has been in America. And I'm like, no, that's the vast majority of the time in the history of the United States, of course, the court has ruled against protecting minority rights. And it's been rare that it has expanded rights for marginalized people. And so that's my fear is yes, I think the lower courts have been doing a really great
这很可能是会发生的，那么你就会上诉到一个在我看来其裁决符合法院悠久历史的最高法院。这就是另一回事了。我认为人们往往把最高法院等同于沃伦法院。我们就是这样概括美国最高法院的历史形象的。而我想说，不，在绝大多数美国历史时期里，法院当然都是作出违背保护少数群体权益的裁决的。它很少扩大边缘化人群的权利。所以这就是我的担忧，是的，我认为下级法院在坚守我们的宪法权利底线方面，
job of kind of holding the line on our constitutional rights. But if I were to think of how we are going to write the history of this period, 20 or 30 years from now, this is going to have to be considered one of the worst courts, most regressive courts in the history of the United States. I don't see how we can see it any other way in my layperson's opinion. Yeah. I mean, so we talked about the inadequacies of the constitution as a backstop to rights, as a legal document. As a symbolic, or at least, I don't know, the best parts of symbolic documents, I suppose, in different moments. It reminds me a little bit
做得真的非常出色。但如果让我设想我们20年或30年后将如何书写这段历史，这段时期必将被视为美国历史上最糟糕、最具倒退性的法院之一。以我这个外行人的看法，我想不出还能怎么看待它。是的。我的意思是，我们讨论了宪法作为权利最后防线、作为法律文件的局限性。作为一个象征性的，或者至少，我不知道，在不同时刻象征性文件最好的部分。这让我想起了一点
of this, what you wrote about your father flying the US flag and how this was a thing that embarrassed you as a teenager and then you began to embrace the idea of it as an adult. Does that sort of analogy hold true for the Constitution or anything like that for you? Interesting question. So one, I don't have to tell either of you this, but definitely not you Elizabeth, like most people don't have any idea what the Constitution says. Exactly. Right. The we the people is literally probably the only thing they can cite and something about the Second Amendment
其中，你写到你父亲升起美国国旗，以及这在青少年时期曾让你感到尴尬，但后来作为成年人你开始接受这个想法。这种类比对宪法或类似事物来说对你成立吗？有趣的问题。首先，我不需要对你们俩说这个，但绝对不是你，伊丽莎白，就像大多数人根本不知道宪法写了什么。完全正确。对，“我们人民”可能真的是他们能引用的唯一内容，还有关于宪法第二修正案的一些事
and maybe a little bit about the First Amendment. Some people might know the 13th. Some things about the right not to incriminate. But most people don't know anything about the Constitution. And it really is not the most interesting read. That's what we're trying to make it a little bit better for people to have, you know, like have friends along the way with them. But yeah, I'm a teacher. I know that struggle. I mean, I was like a nerdy. I just a super nerdy. I had like a
也许还有一点关于第一修正案的内容。有些人可能知道第十三修正案。关于免于自证其罪权利的一些内容。但大多数人对宪法一无所知。而且它确实不是最有趣的可读文本。这就是为什么我们试图让它变得更好一点，让人们知道，你知道的，就像一路上有朋友陪伴。但对，我是一名老师。我知道那种挣扎。我的意思是，我曾经是个书呆子。我只是一个超级书呆子。我有一份
copy of the declaration and the constitutional model ball in my bedroom when I was a kid. It's amazing now, it made for a hard childhood to me. I'm impressed. But I think I have a nuanced view of the Constitution. Again, just taking the rhetorical value of we the people and that it does allow all of us to see ourselves as part of the people and that there is something very powerful about constituting a nation on an idea that's not based on land or bloodline or all of those, you know, things is very powerful. And that is literally the only thing most people know about the constitution, right? They know it's supposed to protect your rights. They couldn't tell you exactly what those rights were, but that we do have rights that
宣言和宪法副本，在我小时候甚至还有个模型球在我的卧室里。这太神奇了，对我来说，这让童年变得很艰难。我很印象深刻。但我认为我对宪法有着微妙的看法。再次强调，仅就“我们人民”的修辞价值而言，它确实让我们所有人都能将自己视为人民的一部分，并且将一个国家建立在一个并非基于土地、血统或所有这些，你知道的，诸如此类事物的理念之上，是非常具有力量的。而这简直是大多数人对宪法的唯一了解，对吧？他们知道它应该保护你的权利。他们说不出这些权利具体是什么，但我们生来就享有权利，我认为这非常有力量。我当然能看到许多缺陷、许多排挤，当然还有，因为这是一份必须被解释的文件，而且几乎总是由我们社会中最精英的人来解释，他们才是被委任解释它的人。对。我能看到所有的挑战和失败，但我能写出一份经得起几个世纪考验的宪法吗？这些人在某种程度上
we are born into, I think is very powerful. I of course can see all the many flaws, all the many exclusions, and of course, the way that because it is a document that must be interpreted and almost always interpreted by the most elite people in our society, they are the ones who are charged with interpreting it. Right. I can see all of the challenges and the failures, but could I write a constitution that would hold up to centuries? It's an impossible task that these men somehow
设法做到了，这是一项不可能的任务。所以我对此有两种看法，就像大多数事情一样。就像我理解为什么我父亲升挂国旗一样。我永远不会升挂它。对。所以我能理解他的爱国主义从何而来，但也得说那不适合我，我个人不会对美国产生那种感觉。但我懂。我想我对宪法也是这种感觉。我认为有很棒的，你知道的，我是一名记者，宪法第一修正案保护言论自由的权利。而我是宪法中唯一受到保护的职业的一部分。我认为这非常有力量。然而，我的书和我的作品却正在被从课堂和图书馆中禁掉。所以我们有这样一个伟大的理念，它可以被解释为掌权者想要它成为的
kind of manage to do. So I'm of two minds on it, like most things. Even with, I understand why my dad flew the flag. I'll never fly it. Right. So I can understand where his patriotism came from, but also say that is not for me, that I personally will not feel that way about the United States. But I get it. And I think I feel that way about the Constitution. I think there are amazing, you know, I'm a journalist, the First Amendment to the Constitution protects the right to free expression. And I am part of the only profession that is protected by me in the Constitution. And I think that's very powerful. And yet, my book and my work is being banned from the classroom, from libraries. So we have this great idea that can be interpreted to mean whatever people in power want to interpret
任何意思。而我认为最让我震惊的事情——其实我也很好奇，我很想听听你们大家是如何经历这一点的——是我们原以为关于治理的所有成文规则其实都是不可执行的。所以，如果你有一个人，他只是决定他根本不在乎宪法怎么说；你有一个国会，它说宪法规定了
it as. And I think the thing that has been most astounding to me, and I'm actually curious to hear, I'd love to hear how you all are experiencing this, is that everything that we kind of thought was codified about governance is not enforceable. So if you have someone who just decides they don't really care what the Constitution says, you have a Congress that says the Constitution lays out
我们监督什么，我们的角色是什么。但如果你有一个国会，它只是说，我们不在乎上面写了什么；如果你有一个法院，它说，其实我们可以拥有一个国王，那宪法算什么？我认为大多数像我这样的普通人，不知何故都相信这份文件确实有某种执行机制，对吧？就像当事情开始脱轨时，我们可以拉响的火警拉杆。而你意识到，它其实只是基于我们拥有这种共同价值观和信仰的协议，
what we oversee, what our roles are. But if you have a Congress that just says, we don't care what that says, if you have a court that says, actually, we can have a king, then what is the Constitution? And I think most regular people like myself somehow believe that this document did have some enforcement mechanism, right? Like the fire alarm lever that we could pull if things started going off the rails. And you're realizing it really was just based on agreement that we had this shared value and belief
而你所需要的只是一个不在乎这一点的人，并且让这个人得到政府其他部门的支持，你就会发现它在某种程度上只是一个门面。但其实我很好奇，这对于你们俩来说是令人惊讶的吗？还是说，你们一直都知道它是如此脆弱？我的意思是，我觉得自己很天真，但我没想到它脆弱到这种程度，我猜是的。我很好奇你们怎么看。这正是我们节目和讨论在最初的核心宗旨，
and all you needed was someone who didn't care about that. And for that person to be backed up by the other branches of government and you see it was a facade in a way. But I'm actually curious if this is, has this been surprising to either of you or did this, you always knew this vulnerable? I mean, I feel naive, but I didn't realize the extent of the vulnerability, I guess. And I'm curious what you think. That was the central tenet of our show and our discussions in the very beginning,
就像，我说，但上面不是说我们不能这样做吗？而伊丽莎白基本上是在说，好吧，这些大多是规范而不是规则，你知道的？我不知道。所以，伊丽莎白，你能详细谈谈吗？在这个时期，这件事对你来说有多惊讶，即使作为一个研究它并了解其细微差别的人。当然。它其实并没有那么令人惊讶。所以，一件事可以既不令人惊讶，同时又绝对让人感到恐惧，对吧？
was like, I'm like, but doesn't it say we can't do this? And Elizabeth is basically saying, well, these are mostly norms and not rules, you know? And I don't know. So Elizabeth, could you expand on this? How surprising was this to you in this time period, even as somebody who studies it and knows the nuances of it. Sure. It's not terribly So it's something can be not surprising and yet absolutely terrifying at the same time, right?
我的意思是，当然，我们身处其中的整个宪政体系本质上是一套荣誉准则。这是一套荣誉准则，我们都同意存在一套特定的规则，我们将遵守它们，不是因为有人会做些什么来惩罚我们——我指的是政府最高层的行动者——而是因为我们都同意这是我们身处其中的体制。现在我们有了一个不同意这套荣誉准则的政府，你知道的，针对政府官员的许多法律原则的基本前提是善意，或者，你知道的，做符合政府最佳利益的事情，
I mean, of course that whole constitutional system that we're in is essentially an honor code It's an honor code where we all agree that there are a certain set of rules and we are gonna abide by them not because Somebody's gonna do something to punish us. I'm talking about the highest actors in government, but because we all agree that this is the system we're in. Now that we have an administration that doesn't agree with the honor code, you know, the basic premise of a lot of legal principles for government actors is like good faith, or, you know, doing what's in the best interests of the government,
无论是国内政策还是外交政策。当你没有那种底层系统在运作时，就会感觉好像一切皆有可能，那真的是、真的是太可怕了。所以不，我并不一定感到惊讶，因为我们多年来一直在目睹这种非常缓慢的侵蚀。而今年——我想你在你的文章中也指出了这一点——一切似乎都以快得多的速度在侵蚀。我们有点进入了超高速模式。而这才是最让人警惕的事情。
whether it's domestic policy or foreign policy. When you don't have that underlying system in place, then it kind of feels like anything goes and that is truly, truly terrifying. So no, I'm not surprised necessarily, because we've been watching this very slow erosion over several years. And this year, and I think you've pointed this out in your writing, everything seems to have eroded at a much faster rate. We've sort of gone at hyper speed. And that's the thing that's most alarming.
是的。我的意思是，这种闪电战式的行政命令的想法有一种诡谲的政治天才感。就像它让我们所有人都措手不及，因为我们在想，这是真的还是假的，还是什么？你知道的，而且法院反应很慢。行政命令非常快。我的意思是，我们讨论过这就像是对宪法进行压力测试的概念，川普政府在第一任期时就
Yeah. I mean, this whole idea of a blitzkrieg of kind of executive orders is a sort of a devious sort of political genius. Like it's sort of like caught all of us off guard, because we're like, what is this real or not or what? You know, like, and the court is slow. Executive orders are very fast. I mean, we've talked about this as the idea of stress testing the Constitution that sort
是这样。我当时认为我们完全不知道，或者我完全不知道情况会变得多糟糕。我其实没想到会有第二任期，所以在最近之前我并没有深入思考过这个问题。但就像，是的，这只是那种让你意识到这一切之中的漏洞的事情，当你看到像第十四修正案这样显而易见的东西时，意识到它现在可能会受到质疑，这让我感到非常震惊。是的。
of the Trump administration was in the first one. I don't think we had no idea or I had no idea how bad it could get. I actually didn't think there was going to be a second Trump administration, so I didn't think about it too hard until pretty recently. But like, yeah, it's just one of those things that you realize the holes in all this, that you see something like as plain as the 14th Amendment and realize that it could be questioned now, is like so shocking to me. Yeah.
嗯，是的。对我和而言，这只是再次思考——这就是我感到自己很天真的时候，因为我想，我知道这个国家能做出什么。是的，它能做出，是的。对，没错。然而，我本无法想象所有的体制、制衡机制都会崩溃。
Well, yeah. And for me, it's just thinking again, like, and this is where I feel very naive, because I'm like, I know what this country is capable of. Yeah, it's capable of, yeah. Right, exactly. And yet, I couldn't have imagined that all the systems, the checks and balances would be collapsed.
就好像总会有某种东西，如果不是国会，那也会是法院或最高法院。就像我说的，我认为下级法院并没有完全按照我认为应该的方式做出每一项裁决，但对我和来说，他们基本上在试图通过他们的裁决来维护宪法。但是，是的，那种你会有这种千载难逢的感觉——我以前说是百年一遇，但现在我觉得这是一个国家历史上面临的一次政客与立场的对齐，你只是，是的，你意识到它，这一切都只是靠着一个承诺、一次握手，甚至是掌心里吐口水的握手勉强维系在一起。这非常可怕，特别是当
It's like there would be something that, if it's not Congress, then it's the courts or the Supreme courts. Like I said, I think the lower courts, they're not doing every rule in the way I think they should, but they're substantially, to me, trying to uphold the Constitution with their rulings. But yeah, just that idea that you would have this kind of once in a, I used to say once in a century, but now I'm like once in the history of a country, alignment and politician, you just, yeah, you realize it was, it was just all held together with a, with a promise, a handshake like spit in the palm handshake. And that's very frightening, especially when
你是少数群体或少数族群的成员时，就会明白这一切是多么脆弱。再说一次，我并不震惊。我以此为生。我刚刚还在密西西比州，跟那些为了南方的民主而坐牢上百次的人在一起。所以我知道这个国家能做出什么。我没想到黑人度过了
you are a member of minority grouper groups to understand how fragile this has been. And again, I'm not shocked. Like I studied this for a living. I just was in Mississippi with, you know, people who were arrested a hundred times fighting for democracy in the South. So I know what this country is capable of. I didn't think the America that black people have lived in
我们大部分人一生的那个美国，会成为现在每个人都要生活的美国。这确实有点令人震惊。而且我认为，是的，我认为大多数人很难接受的一点是，现在正在发生的事情——我们的规范以及对政府善意的期待的崩溃——就像是，
most of our lives would be the America that everybody's gonna live in now. And which is a little shocking. And I think, yeah, I think one of the things that's hard, I think for most people to wrap their minds around is that what's happening now, this collapse of our norms and our expectations of good faith in government is like,
这不像是，哦，还会有下一届政府，我们会想办法解决的。这是一个，你知道的，将产生代际、多代人影响的变革。你知道的，有时——我讨厌对此表现得非常愤世嫉俗——我在想，在我有生之年，这一切中的很大一部分甚至任何部分会被彻底撤销吗。我不知道你怎么看。我也是这么想的。我认为正是那种美国的乐观主义和一厢情愿，才导致人们以为我们只需要撑到下一次选举就行了。我不认为你看到这种程度的规范遭到破坏，还会觉得一切能回到从前。
it's not like, oh, there'll be the next administration, and we'll figure it out. This is a, you know, a generational, multi-generational effect change that's going to happen. And you know, sometimes, and I hate to sound really cynical about this, is like, I wonder whether in my lifetime, a lot of this will be on any of this will be completely undone. I don't know how you feel about it. That's the same. I think that it's that American optimism and wishful thinking that leads people to think we just have to get to the next election. I don't think you can see this type of destruction of norms and think that it just goes back.
覆水难收，瓶中妖魔不会轻易被放回。我担心在看到真正的转机之前，还会有大量的破坏发生。我们还没触底，连边都还没沾到。我不是在说……不，我同意。但是，规范的侵蚀是否也在朝着更多实现我所相信的事情的方向发展？你知道我的意思吗？
The genie will not be put back in the bottle anytime soon. And I fear there's going to be a lot of destruction before we start to see a real turnaround. And we haven't hit bottom, not even close. I don't say that. No, I agree. But like, is there something about the norms eroding towards getting more things that I believe in? You know what I mean?
我难道不能利用规范来把事情变得更好吗？你知道我的意思吗？如果下一任总统通过闪电战般的行政命令来改变这一切，扩充法院呢？既然破坏规范的封印已经被打破，你是否能看到一个为了正义而打破规范的世界？我的意思是，这是可能的，对吧？我的意思是，沃伦法院就是为了正义而打破规范，
Can I not use norms to make things better? You know what I mean? What if the next president has executive orders that Blitzkrieg can change all this, pack the court? Now that the seal is broken on norm breaking, do you see a world in which norm breaking for good happens? I mean, it's possible, right? I mean, the Warren court was norm breaking for good,
我会这么说，但你知道，那些都只是昙花一现。我不是政治记者或政治评论员，但我还没有从主流民主党身上看到任何能让你相信将会有某种巨大反制力量的迹象。我想你可以看看纽约市，并从我们的市长初选中看到这种可能性，但随后你也会看到
I would say, but you know, those have been blips. I'm not a political reporter or a pundit, but I have yet to see anything from the Main Street Democratic Party that would have you believe that there is going to be some huge counter force. I think you can look at New York City and see the possibility with our mayoral primary, but then you also see
不是共和党的力量在对抗这种变革，而是民主党的力量在多大程度上对抗这种变革。对此我想说，你知道的，我甚至不知道有什么激进的，那个人的主张是全民医保、全民育儿、免费公交，听起来棒极了。但我认为这就是我在采访和与民主党基层的选民交谈时发现的，他们只是觉得那个本该代表他们利益的党派，并没有像另一个党派推进他们所做的事情那样，为了正义去行使权力。
how much not Republican power is coming against that, but how much Democratic power is coming against that change. Which I'm like, you know, I don't even know what's so radical, the man is universal health care, universal child care, free buses, sounds great. But I think that's the thing that when I'm interviewing and talking to people who are the base of the Democratic party is just the belief that the party that's supposed to be representing their interests does not wield power for good in the way that the other party is wielding power for what they're doing.
所以，是的，这是可能的。我的意思是，在选举前，我跟许多川普选民谈过，出人意料的川普选民。我不去采访那种，你知道的，我不是那种去报道川普集会或者去采访那些人人都知道是川普选民的人。我采访的是那些会让你感到意外的川普选民。其中有相当一部分人说，我投票给他是因为他要把一切都炸毁。我不知道，我不喜欢他，
So yeah, it's possible. I mean, I talked to, before the election, I talked to a lot of Trump voters, surprising Trump voters. I don't interview, like, you know, I'm not the person who's covering the Trump rally or like the people you know are Trump voters. I talked to people who like you would be surprised at Trump voters. And there was a significant number of them who said, I'm voting for him because he's going to blow everything up. I don't, I don't like them.
我不同意他的任何政策，但情况太糟糕了，民主党也处于这种停滞状态。他们都在拿同一个群体的钱。他们就想找个能把一切炸毁的人，这样我们就可以开启一些新东西。现在我就会觉得，好吧，但你把一切炸毁了却得不到你想要的东西，而且在你炸毁它并抱着希望的同时，人们将承受巨大的痛苦。
I don't agree with any of his policies, but things are so bad and the Democratic party is in such stasis. They're all taking money from the same people. And they're like, I just want someone who will blow it all up so we can like start something new. Now me, I'm like, okay, but you can blow it all up and don't get that thing you want, but also there's so much suffering that people are gonna have to bear while you're blowing it up, hoping.
但人们觉得我们的整个政治体制已经破碎了。所以我认为，总有一种潜力，那就是在毁灭之中，你可以建立一个崭新且更好的世界。但我认为历史告诉我们，胜算并不站在我们这边。没错。我想是的。
But people feel that our political system in general is broken. So I think there is always a potential that out of destruction, you can build a new and better world. But I think history tells us the odds are not in our favor. That's right. I think that's right.
好吧，妮可·汉娜-琼斯，非常感谢你来到节目中并与我们探讨宪法。我们非常感激，也很感谢你的宝贵时间。不，谢谢你们。我很少有机会在我的正常舒适区之外进行对话。这真的很有趣，所以谢谢你们，我也很期待收听这个播客系列。谢谢。那么说到序言，里面其实有很多内容。
Well, Nicole Hannah-Jones, thank you so much for being on the show and talking about the Constitution with us. We really appreciate it and appreciate your time. No, thank you. I seldom get to have conversations out of my normal zone. This was really fun. So thank you and I look forward to listening to the podcast series. Thank you. So when it comes to the preamble, there's a lot going on with it.
我们和妮可主要讨论了其中的“我们人民”部分，这非常合理，因为它算得上是最大胆的修辞点缀。而且这也是莫里斯州长（Governor Morris）实际修改过的地方之一，原本可能是像“我们各州或各殖民地”之类的，后来改成了“我们人名”。但这里面还有更多内容，比如建立公正、确保国内安宁、提供共同防务，所有这些标准的内容，促进公共福利，这是许多国家都在做的事情。然后还有，为我们自己和后代获得自由的福祉，这听起来格局宏大，你知道我的意思吗？所以我们可以谈论
And we mostly, with Nicole, talked about the we the people part of this, which makes a ton of sense because it is kind of the biggest rhetorical flourish. And one of those things that Governor Morris actually changed, it was going to be like we the states of the colonies and change to we the people. But there's so much more in here, establishing justice and ensuring domestic tranquility, provide for the common defense, all those kind of standard stuff, promote the general welfare, what a lot of things countries do. And then it's like, secure the blessings of liberty to ourselves and our posterity, where you're like going big, you know what I mean? So we can talk
所有这些事情。但这些内容在宪法中出现得要晚得多。我的意思是，这里有一个真正的序言，它本意是像在向你介绍这些概念，但它们在许多修正案中得到了更深入的探讨，例如。对。我们可以把序言看作是对我们肯定会涉及的不同主题的一种示意。什么是提供共同防务？或者说自由可能是宪法中最具争议的词汇之一。
about all those things. But these things show up much later in the Constitution. I mean, there's a true preamble and that is supposed to like, it's kind of introducing you to these concepts, but they get explored more greatly, like in a lot of the amendments, for example. Right. We can think of the preamble as kind of gestures to different themes that we're definitely going to pick up. What does it mean to have providing for the common defense? Or liberty is maybe one of the most contested words in the Constitution.
所以，是的，它是含糊不清的，可能非常刻意地如此。我们很可能会在我们的讨论过程中，一次又一次地审视这些，让我们称之为序言主题的东西。好的，谢谢你和我探讨宪法。休息之后，我们将讨论一些当今正在发生的宪政危机。当我们开发这个节目的构想时，我们知道我们不想失去《川普能教给我们关于宪法的事》中探讨时事的那一部分。
So yes, it is vague, probably very deliberately so. And we are probably going to look at these, let's call them the preambles themes over and over again during the course of our discussions. Well, thank you for talking with me about the Constitution. And now we're going to talk about some constitutional crisis that is happening in the present day after the break. When we were developing the idea for the show, we knew we didn't want to lose the what Trump can teach us about con law aspect of talking about current events.
因此，每个月在与嘉宾的读书俱乐部解说环节之后，伊丽莎白都将运用宪法来解释新闻中正在发生的事情。所以，伊丽莎白，在我们录音的现在是7月16日下午1点45分。我们主要聊什么？好吧，在1970年3月，吉诺·贾科贝利（Gino Giacobelli）接受了美联社关于他工作的采访。他的生活并不容易。
So each month after our book club breakdown section with the guest, Elizabeth is going to use constitutional law to explain something happening in the news. So Elizabeth, it is July 16th at 1.45 PM as we're recording this. What are we gonna be talking about today? Well, in March of 1970, Gino Giacobelli gave a interview with the Associated Press about his job. And his life was not easy.
吉诺作为新泽西州哈肯萨克的一名美国邮政职员，工作14年后的实发工资是每周109美元。他必须养活妻子、成年的女儿和两个孙辈。根据采访，吉诺的抱负并不宏大，但他抱怨说，大多数晚上的晚餐都是猪肉拌豆子或豆子拌培根。而他真正想要的是他所谓的半像样的饭菜，也许是一个汉堡或一块牛排。吉诺告诉美联社记者，他的邮政同事中有27人已经申请了食品券。
Gino's take-home pay after 14 years as a US postal clerk in Hackensack, New Jersey was $109 a week. He had to support his wife, his adult daughter and his two grandchildren. Now according to the interview, Gino's ambitions weren't too grand, but he complained that most nights dinner was pork and beans or beans and bacon. And what he really wanted was what he called a halfway decent meal, maybe a hamburger or a steak. And Gino told the AP reporter that 27 of his fellow postal workers had applied for food stamps.
他自己也差不多快要申请了。当时，邮政工人的工资很低，因为国会只对他们的工资进行了小幅上调。在20世纪60年代，邮政工人身兼数职是很常见的事。到了吉诺接受采访时，许多邮政工人的收入刚刚勉强维持在贫困线上。然而，在1970年初，国会提出了一项法案，给予邮政工人5.4%的加薪，这低于通货膨胀率。这就是那个在前一年给自己投票加薪41%的同一个国会。
And he was getting pretty close to it himself. Now, postal worker salaries were low because Congress had only raised their wages in small amounts. In the 1960s, it wasn't uncommon for postal workers to have multiple jobs. By the time of Gino's interview, many postal workers were just above the poverty line. Yet, in early 1970, Congress proposed a bill that would give postal workers a 5.4% raise less than the rate of inflation. This was the same Congress that had voted in themselves a 41% raise the year before.
在纽约市，国家信件递送员工会最大分会的邮政工人要求罢工，但他们的工会领导人拒绝了。原因之一是，邮政工人罢工实际上是违法的。但会员们进行了投票，并决定无论如何都要罢工。这是一场野猫罢工（未经工会批准的罢工）。
In New York City, postal workers in the largest branch of the National Letter Carriers Union demanded a strike, but their union leaders refused. One reason was it was actually illegal for postal workers to strike. But the members took a vote and they decided to strike anyway. A wildcat strike.
于是，在1970年3月18日，没错，美国历史上最大规模的野猫罢工拉开了帷幕。这场邮政工人罢工从纽约开始，几天之内蔓延到芝加哥、密尔沃基、旧金山和其他城市。现在，你必须记住这是1970年。当时没有互联网，没有我们今天所知的在线生活。因此，我们今天在网上做的所有寻常事情——付账单、领工资、享受福利、办理业务——完全都是通过邮件进行的，而在某些城市，邮件已经完全停止了。所以，
And thus began on March 18th, that's right, 1970, the largest wildcat strike in American history. A postal workers strike that began in New York and then spread to Chicago, Milwaukee, San Francisco and other cities within days. Now, you have to remember this was 1970. There's no internet, no online life as we know it today. And so all of the ordinary things we all do online today, pay bills, get paid, receive benefits, transact business, completely happened through the mail, which in some cities had completely stopped. So the
尼克松政府诉诸法院，法官下令工人停止罢工。但记住，他们罢工是违法的。邮政工人置法庭的话于不顾，股市应声下跌。华尔街的一位交易员说，我不知道没有了邮件我们要怎么运作。于是，在1970年3月23日，尼克松总统通过电视向公众发表讲话，宣布进入国家紧急状态。他将派遣军队前往纽约市
Nixon administration went to court and a judge ordered the workers to stop. But remember it was illegal for them to strike. The postal workers ignored what the court said and the stock market slid. One trader on Wall Street said, I don't see how we're going to operate without the mail. And so on March 23rd, 1970, President Nixon addressed the public on TV and announced a national emergency. He would be sending the military to New York City
来投递邮件。尼克松在电视上说，作为总统，我将履行我的宪政职责，确保这些服务得以维持。没错。尼克松总统授权部署了数千名陆军、空军、海军、海军陆战队和国民警卫队员，来执行被称为“绘图手行动”（Operation Graphic Hand）的任务。根据尼克松的第3972号行政公告，26,000名部队被派往纽约市
to deliver the mail. On TV, Nixon said, as president, I shall meet my constitutional responsibility to see that those services are maintained. That's right. President Nixon authorized the deployment of thousands of members of the Army, Air Force, Navy, Marine Corps, and the National Guard to implement what was called Operation Graphic Hand. And under Nixon's Executive Proclamation 3972, 26,000 troops were sent to New York City to
分拣邮件并向企业投递邮件。问题是，士兵们并不擅长这个。不用说也知道。1970年，邮政服务通常依赖于每小时能处理一千多封信件的手工分拣员。但当《纽约时报》在布鲁克林采访专家阿诺德·格雷（Arnold Gray）时，他是这么说的：你们听说过波士顿惨案和米莱大屠杀。明天你们将看到纽约邮件大屠杀。
sort mail and to deliver mail to businesses. The problem was the soldiers were not very good at it. You don't say. In 1970, the Postal Service often relied on hand sorters who could handle more than a thousand letters an hour. But when the New York Times interviewed specialist Arnold Gray in Brooklyn, here's what he said. You've heard of the Boston massacre and the Mealy massacre. Tomorrow you're going to see the New York Mail Massacre.
我对邮局一无所知。我是一名医务兵。“绘图手行动”的部队确实处理了1280万件邮件，速度非常慢。对尼克松来说幸运的是，罢工并没有持续太久。1970年的野猫邮政罢工于3月25日结束，就在它开始仅仅八天后，邮政工会领导人承诺与联邦政府进行谈判。最终国会确实批准了给邮政工人的加薪，尼克松后来签署了
I don't know a thing about the post office. I'm a medic. The forces of Operation GraphiCAN did process 12.8 million pieces of mail very slowly. Luckily for Nixon, the strike didn't last very long. The Wildcat Postal Strike of 1970 ended on March 25th, just eight days after it began, and postal union leaders promised to negotiate with the federal government. Ultimately Congress did approve a pay raise for postal workers, and Nixon eventually signed
《邮政重组法案》，承认了他们集体谈判的权利。并且它创建了我们今天所知的美国邮政署。我愿意相信吉诺·贾科贝利因此偶尔能吃上一块牛排了。是的，让我们希望如此。作为总统，尼克松行使了作为三军统帅对军队的权力。但在1970年的野猫邮政罢工中，
the Postal Reorganization Act, which recognized their rights to collective bargaining. And it created the U.S. Postal Service that we know today. And I'd like to think that Gino Giacobilli was able to have a stake now and then as a result. Yeah, let's hope so. And as president, Nixon used his powers as commander in chief over the military. But in the Wildcat Postal Strike of 1970,
我们当时并没有处于战争状态，也没有卷入任何外国军事承诺，但从邮政罢工到如今川普将军队用于其大规模驱逐计划之间，存在着一条贯穿线。那么这两者之间有什么联系呢？好吧，让我们从一些核心原则开始。在我们的法律体系中，我们有着一个根深蒂固的信念，即军队不应该被用于
we weren't at war or in any foreign commitment, but there's a through line from the postal strike to present Trump's use of the military for his mass deportation program. So what is the connection between those two things? Well, let's begin with some core principles. In our legal system, we have this really deeply held belief that the military shouldn't be used
民事执法。事实上，这是《独立宣言》中冗长抱怨清单中的一项，对吧？我们抱怨的事情之一就是，乔治国王在和平时期在我们的领土上维持常备军，未经我们立法机构的同意。正是这种对国内事务中常备军的深深疑虑，
in civilian law enforcement. In fact, it's one of the long list of complaints in the Declaration of Independence, right? One of the things we've complained about was that King George kept among us in times of peace, standing armies without the consent of our legislatures. And it's that deep suspicion about standing armies in domestic affairs.
这也是我们的宪法将一位平民——总统——置于对军队控制地位的原因之一。但另一方面，宪法也对联邦政府在各州安全方面强加了责任。例如，宪法的保障条款要求联邦政府向各州提供保护，免受外国侵略，
That's one of the reasons our constitution puts a civilian, the president, in control of the military. But on the other hand, the Constitution also imposes responsibilities on the federal government when it comes to the security of the states. So for instance, the guarantee clause of the Constitution requires the federal government to provide states with protection from foreign invasion
以及免受该条款所称的国内暴力。根据宪法，国会有权召集民兵来执行联邦法律。因此，我们防范针对平民的常备军，同时也为紧急情况保留一定权力的主要方式，就是《本土防卫法》（Posse Comitatus Act）。它只有一句话。所以，罗曼，你为什么不读一下呢？
and from what the clause calls domestic violence. And Congress has the authority to call out the militia under the Constitution to enforce federal law. And so the major way we protect against having a standing army against civilians, but also having some power for emergencies is the Posse Comitatus Act. And it's just one sentence. So Roman, why don't you read it?
好的。我的意思是，这是一句很长的句子，但它是一句话。因此，任何人，除非在宪法或国会法案明确授权的情况下和环境下，故意使用陆军、海军、海军陆战队、空军或太空军——哦，这是个新加入的军种——的任何部分作为治安民兵（Posse Comitatus），或以其他方式执行法律，将根据本法被处以罚金或监禁不超过两年，或两者并罚。
Okay. I mean, it's a long sentence, but it's one sentence. So, whoever, except in cases and under circumstances expressly authorized by the Constitution or Act of Congress, willfully uses any part of the Army, the Navy, the Marine Corps, the Air Force, or the Space Force, well that's a new addition, as the Posse Comitatus, or otherwise, to execute the laws shall be fined under this title or imprisoned not more than two years or both.
所以这出自哪里？我们是什么时候把太空军加到这个名单里的？挺近的，对吧？是的，没错。所以“Posse comitatus”这个术语实际上指的是英国普通法中的权力。所以我们要追溯到很久以前，即治安官指挥当地社区的男子
So where does this come from? And when did we add Space Force to this list? Pretty recently, right? Yeah, that's right. So the term Posse comitatus actually refers to the power in English common law. So we're going back a long time, the power of the sheriff to command local men
协助他执法的权力。所以如果你看过那种老西部电影，里面治安官说，嘿，大家伙，我们要组建一个民兵队去抓坏人，那就是同一个意思，对吧？但有了《本土防卫法》，伙计，那就是同一个意思。哇。
in the community to help him enforce the law. So if you've ever seen like an old Western movie where the sheriff says, hey everybody, we're gonna get a posse together to catch the bad guy, that's the same idea, right? But with the Posse Comitatus Act, guy, that's the same idea. Wow. Right? But with the Posse Comitatus Act, I'm actually thinking of our earlier conversation
对吧？但有了《本土防卫法》——我其实想到了我们之前与妮可·汉娜-琼斯的对话，因为该法案本身的历史实际上与内战和种族主义交织在一起。在南方重建时期，联邦军队占领了前邦联地区，其中包括作为这些联邦军队一部分的黑人士兵。他们去那里是为了确保联邦法律得到尊重，特别是涉及保护投票权时。而南方人将这些部队视为一种羞辱。所以我在这里浓缩了
with Nikole Hannah-Jones, because the act itself has a history that's intertwined with the Civil War and racism, actually. During Reconstruction, federal troops occupied the former Confederacy, and that included black soldiers who were part of those federal troops. And they were all there to ensure that the federal laws would be respected, especially when it came to protecting voting rights. And Southerners saw these troops as a humiliation. So I'm condensing
大量的内战历史，但为了解决争夺激烈的1876年总统大选——拉瑟福德·海斯险胜——海斯最终同意从南方撤出联邦军队。是的，这在当时实际上有效地结束了重建。完全正确。它结束了重建以及内战后为南方黑人争取权利的承诺。
a lot of Civil War history here, but in order to settle the hotly contested 1876 presidential election, which Rutherford Hayes barely won, Hayes ended up agreeing to remove federal troops from the South. Yeah, which pretty much effectively ended reconstruction at that point. Exactly. It ends reconstruction and the promise
但当然，如果你阅读该法案，你永远不会知道这一点。所以你拥有这样一部有着不那么光彩起源的法案，但它依然是一部维护我们法律体系中重要原则的联邦法律。除了进行一些小改动，比如将太空军纳入其中，
of securing rights for black Americans in the South after the Civil War. But of course, if you read the act, you'd never know that. So you have this act with less than savory origins, but nevertheless a federal law that does uphold an important principle in our legal system. And apart from some minor changes, like the inclusion of the Space Force,
自从它最初通过以来，它基本保持不变。它究竟是如何防止这个问题的？它在这里到底列出了什么？因此，该法案表达了这样一个总体概念，即我们不应该在美国拥有常备军的这种推定。但问题是法律允许例外情况。除非得到宪法或国会法案的明确授权，否则你不能组建治安民兵。现在，“由宪法授权”这部分
it has remained mostly unchanged since it was originally passed. How exactly does it prevent the problem? Like what is it laying out here? So the act expresses this general idea, this presumption that we should not have a standing army in the United States. But the problem is that the law permits exceptions. You can't have a posse comitatus unless expressly authorized by the Constitution or Act of Congress. Now the authorized by the Constitution part
意义不大，因为宪法中实际上没有任何内容具体允许我们这样做。另一方面，国会通过了法律，为《本土防卫法》创造了例外。换句话说，国会有时可能会说，以下是总统可以在民事背景下使用军队的情况。嗯哼。而这种监禁的威胁，在这个法案中谁会被监禁呢？
doesn't mean much because there's actually nothing in the Constitution that specifically allows us to do this. On the other hand, Congress has passed laws that create exceptions to the Posse Comitatus Act. In other words, Congress may sometimes say, here are situations where the president can use the military in a civilian context. Mm-hmm. And this threat of imprisonment, who is going to be imprisoned in this act?
这是个好问题，因为我们不知道。并没有过这样的起诉。所以这仍然是个谜。好的。那么有哪些例外情况允许组建民兵呢？好吧，《本土防卫法》的主要例外被称为《暴动法》（Insurrection Act）。这是我们给一系列最初于1792年通过的法律起的名字。《暴动法》允许总统使用联邦军队，这包括联邦化的国民警卫队，在三种情况下使用。第一种是当某一州请求联邦帮助
That's a good question because we don't know. There haven't been any prosecutions like that. So that remains a kind of mystery. Okay. And what are some of these exceptions that would allow for Posse to be formed? Well, the primary exception to the Posse Comitatus Act is called the Insurrection Act. It's a name we give to a series of laws that were first passed in 1792. And the Insurrection Act allows the president to use federal troops, and that includes federalized national guard troops in three situations. The first is when a state asks for federal help
镇压法律所称的暴动时。第二种是当总统确定你需要军队来执行美国法律或镇压叛乱时。第三种是当总统在一个州内使用军队来处理法律所称的任何暴动、国内暴力、非法联合或阴谋，这些行为阻碍了联邦法律的执行。
to suppress what the law calls an insurrection. The second is when the president determines that you need the military to enforce the laws of the United States or to suppress rebellion. And the third is when the president uses the military in a state to address what the law calls any insurrection, domestic violence, unlawful combination or conspiracy that hinders the execution of federal law.
所以对我们来说，这里重要的事情是注意到这里的军队可以包括国民警卫队。现在，国民警卫队通常受各州管辖，但在适当的情况下，总统被允许将这些部队联邦化。因此，当总统这样做时，国民警卫队本质上变得与其余军队没有什么不同。
So the important thing here for us is to note that the military here can include the National Guard. Now the National Guard is normally under the authority of each state, but the president is allowed to federalize these troops in the right circumstances. So when the president does that, the National Guard essentially becomes no different than the rest of the military.
所以考虑到这三个例外情况，这被使用过多少次？也许哪一个是其中最常见的？我猜由州提出请求是最常见的一种。是的，没错。这些例外情况已经被使用过相当多次。总统最常使用《暴动法》的情况，我猜由州提出请求是其中最常见的一种。是的，没错。这些例外情况已经被使用过相当多次。
So considering these three exceptions, like how many times has this been used? And maybe which one is the most common one? I imagine the state asking for it is the most common one. Yeah, that's right. The exceptions have been used quite a bit. Most often presidents have used the Insurrection Act I imagine the state asking for it is one of the most common ones. Yeah, that's right. The exceptions have been used quite a bit.
最常见的是，总统在发生公民骚乱时利用《暴动法》派遣联邦军队，这种情况大约发生过30次。例如，老布什总统在1992年洛杉矶罗德尼·金骚乱期间援引《暴动法》派遣了联邦军队。所以在那种情况下，你可以看到这是在州长的请求或至少是同意下发生的。
Most often, presidents have used the Insurrection Act to send federal troops in times of civil unrest, and it's happened about 30 times. And so, for example, the first President Bush in 1992 invoked the Insurrection Act to send out federal troops during the Rodney King riots in LA. So in that kind of situation, you can see that that happens with the request
美国历史上唯一一次显著的例外是1965年，当时约翰逊总统向亚拉巴马州派遣了军队，但那是为了保护从塞尔马游行到蒙哥马利的民权活动人士。而那位不同意的州长是乔治·华莱士（George Wallace），他是一个相当公开的种族隔离主义者和种族主义者。
or at least the consent of the state's governor. The one notable time in American history when a president did not do that was in 1965 when LBJ sent troops to Alabama, but that was to protect civil rights activists who are marching from Selma to Montgomery. And the non-consenting governor was George Wallace, who was a pretty open segregationist and racist.
所以你能理解他为什么这么做。因此，让这一切最顺利的最简单方法就是让州长参与进来，因为这会自动将你带入可以接受的领域。对，所以你需要两件事。我的意思是，就州长予以配合而言，这是政治上可接受的，
So you can understand why he did that. And so the easiest way to make this the most smooth is for the governor to be on board with this, because that automatically gets you into the territory of it being acceptable. Right, so you need the two things. I mean, like it politically acceptable in terms of the governor going along with it,
但同时还必须满足《暴动法》下的那些特定条件。总而言之，根据联邦法律，我们有一部来自重建时期之后的19世纪法规，它阻止总统在未经国会承认例外的情况下对平民动用军队。而《本土防卫法》的主要例外
but then also those certain conditions have to be met under the Insurrection Act. So to sum up under federal law, we have a 19th century statute from after reconstruction that stops the president from calling out the military against civilians unless Congress has recognized an exception. And the major exception here to the Posse Comitatus Act
就是《暴动法》。现在让我们转向当前正在发生的事情，对吧？所以你、我和所有人都看到了移民和海关执法局（ICE）官员不断升级的移民执法行动。因此出现了这些病毒式传播的视频，戴着口罩的ICE特工四处搜寻无证移民，在餐馆、家得宝（Home Depot）、农场、甚至学校，
is the Insurrection Act. So now let's turn to what's happening now, right? So you and I and everyone has seen the ratcheting up of immigration enforcement by ICE officers. So there have been these viral videos about masked ICE officers turning, looking for undocumented people at restaurants, home depots, farms, even schools,
有时甚至在法院下令出庭的地点，粗暴地把人抓走并带走。这太可怕了。是的，这太令人作呕了。因此在一些城市，人们一直在抗议这些突袭搜查。在6月初，在发生了几次ICE突袭之后，洛杉矶市中心爆发了大规模抗议活动。
and sometimes even at court ordered appearances, just sort of snatching people and taking them away. It's been terrible. Yeah, it's disgusting. So in some cities, people have been protesting these raids. And in early June, large protests began in downtown Los Angeles after several ICE raids had taken place.
现在，与洛杉矶警察局确实发生了一些冲突，但它们大多是和平的。但在6月7日，川普总统发布了一份官方备忘录，授权将国民警卫队联邦化，并将现役武装部队部署到备忘录所说的发生抗议的地点。这里的想法是，武装部队将提供武力支持，以确保ICE特工能够进行逮捕。
Now, there were definitely some clashes with the Los Angeles Police Department, but they were mostly peaceful. But on June 7th, President Trump issued an official memorandum that authorized the federalization of the National Guard and the deployment of active duty armed forces to what the memo said were locations where protests are occurring. The idea here is that armed forces would provide the muscle in making sure that ICE officers could make their arrests.
因此，国防部长皮特·海格塞斯（Pete Hegseth）召集了数千名加州国民警卫队员进行为期60天的联邦服役。6月8日，300名加州国民警卫队部队抵达洛杉矶市中心，随后还有许多其他人加入。其中包括700名现役海军陆战队员，他们也作为该公告的一部分前往洛杉矶。所以川普是依靠《暴动法》
And so Secretary of Defense Pete Hegseth called several thousand members of the California National Guard into federal service for 60 days. On June 8th, 300 California National Guard troops arrived in downtown LA, and they were joined by many others later. And that included 700 active duty Marines who also went to LA as part of this proclamation. So is Trump relying on the Insurrection Act
来使其合法的吗？好吧，每个人都以为他可能会这么做，但令人惊讶的答案是没有。他本可以轻而易举地做历任总统做过几十次的事。这就是奇怪的地方。川普并没有依靠这个相当受认可的例外。即使《暴动法》在某些使用上存在争议，它过去确实被使用过。相反，川普依靠的是另一项法规。
to make this legal? Well, everybody thought he might, but the surprising answer is no. He could have easily have done what presidents have done dozens of times. And that's the strange thing. Trump is not relying on this pretty well recognized exception. Even if the Insurrection Act is controversial in some uses, it's definitely been used before. So instead, Trump is relying on a different statute.
要使其合法化吗？嗯，每个人都以为他会，但令人惊讶的答案是没有。他本可以轻而易举地做到历任总统做过几十次的事情。这就是奇怪的地方。特朗普并没有依赖这个广为人知的例外。即使《暴动法》在某些使用场景下颇具争议，但它以前确实被使用过。因此，特朗普转而依赖了一项不同的法规。
It's called 10 USC 12406. It's an act that allows a president yeah very catchy. It's an act that allows a president to call up the National Guard in a case of what that law says is a rebellion or danger of a rebellion against the United States or if the president is unable with the regular forces to execute federal law. But the weird thing about this law is that it's typically been used as almost kind of like a technical call up for the National Guard. So presidents have typically used the Insurrection Act as kind of the legal reason why they're calling up the National Guard. And then they use this law in conjunction with the Insurrection Act as the technical
这项法律被称为《美国法典》第10编第12406条。这是一项允许总统——听起来确实挺顺口的——这是一项允许总统在发生法律所规定的“针对美国的叛乱或叛乱危险”，或者总统无法动用正规部队执行联邦法律的情况下，调动国民警卫队的法律。但这部法律奇怪的地方在于，它通常被用作调动国民警卫队的一种程序性手段。因此，总统通常以《暴动法》作为调动国民警卫队的法律依据，然后结合《暴动法》来使用这项法律作为程序性依据
and now we're calling up the National Guard, kind of a way to shift control of the National Guard from the state's governor to the president. So is Trump the first person to do this type of maneuver? Well, apparently it has been used one time before, during the 1970 Wildcat postal strike. Oh, here we go. There we go. In fact, that is the example we see cited by the state of California in their lawsuit against the Trump administration, a lawsuit that was filed in federal court just a day
而现在我们要调动国民警卫队了，这实际上是将国民警卫队的指挥权从州长转移给总统的一种方式。那么，特朗普是第一个采取这种手段的人吗？好吧，显然在此之前已经使用过一次，那是在1970年的野生邮政工人罢工期间。哦，原来如此。确实如此。事实上，加利福尼亚州在起诉特朗普政府的诉讼中，引用的正是这个例子。这起联邦诉讼是在第一批联邦化国民警卫队部队抵达洛杉矶仅仅一天之后
after the first federalized National Guard troops arrived in Los Angeles. The state argues that this statute, again, 10 USC 12406, has only been used by a president once, and for what the state calls highly unusual circumstances not presented here. And so from what we've just talked about, you can see there are enormous differences. We were not thinking in the 1970s that the soldiers called up in that emergency proclamation
在联邦法院提起的。该州辩称，这项法规（即《美国法典》第10编第12406条）此前只被总统使用过一次，而且是在该州所称的“在此并未出现的、高度不寻常的情况下”。因此，从我们刚才讨论的内容中，你可以看出它们之间存在巨大的差异。在20世纪70年代，人们绝不会想到在那个紧急公告中被召集的士兵
were going to be used for anything but like the most beneficial, you know, innocuous purposes, which was deliver the mail, right? Right, right, right. Although it does seem like calling the wildcat strike of the postal workers a rebellion against the US seems a little far reaching too. Oh, well, so presumably that would have been
会被用于除了最有利、最无害的目的之外的任何事情，也就是送信，对吧？对，对，对。尽管把邮政工人的野猫罢工称为针对美国的叛乱，听起来确实也显得有些牵强。哦，好吧，所以大概那并不是
not that basis, but remember it's also if you're unable to execute federal law. And since like delivering the mail is an essential part of it's even in the constitution, right, that we would establish post offices, that mail not being delivered at all was not being able to execute federal law. So is the state of California suing Trump because he's not invoking the Interaction Act, or what is the basis of the lawsuit? Okay, so that's a good question. So California here is saying, look, what is Trump relying on?
基于这个理由，但请记住，这也适用于你无法执行联邦法律的情况。既然送信是其中的一个重要组成部分——甚至宪法中也规定了我们要建立邮局——那么邮件完全无法投递，就构成了无法执行联邦法律的情况。那么，加利福尼亚州起诉特朗普是因为他没有援引《暴动法》，还是这起诉讼的依据是什么？好的，这是一个好问题。加利福尼亚州在这里的意思是，等等，特朗普依据的是什么？
He's relying on this not typically used statute. And even if you look at that statute, the required bases are not here when it comes to ICE engaging in their immigration raids and people mostly peacefully protesting against them. So the state is not challenging the use of the law saying that Trump can never use this ever. They're saying it's just that the right conditions
他依据的是这部通常不被使用的法规。即便你去看那部法规，当涉及到移民及海关执法局（ICE）进行移民突袭以及人们针对他们进行绝大多数是和平的抗议时，所要求的条件在这里根本不具备。因此，该州并不是在挑战这项法律本身，也不是说特朗普永远不能使用它。他们是说，只是正确的条件
are not present here. But let's think about what the complaint is actually doing or what the federal lawsuit's about. California says, look, 12406, that's the federal statute, only allows the president to call up the National Guard when there's an invasion by a foreign country, when there's a rebellion, or when the president can't enforce federal law.
在这里并不具备。但让我们想一想，这份诉状实际上在做什么，或者说联邦诉讼到底是关于什么的。加利福尼亚州表示，你看，12406条——也就是那个联邦法规——只允许总统在外国入侵、发生叛乱，或者总统无法强制执行联邦法律时调动国民警卫队。
Now, obviously, there's been no invasion by a foreign country, so we can toss that out immediately. And California argued, look, this isn't even a rebellion. Even if there were some people who were arrested during the protest, that doesn't transform a protest into a rebellion against the United States. And second, it's not even true that the Trump administration can't enforce the law
现在，很显然，并没有来自外国的入侵，所以我们可以直接把这个排除在外。加利福尼亚州辩称，看，这甚至连叛乱都算不上。即便有一些人在抗议期间被捕，这也不能把一场抗议变成针对美国的叛乱。其次，特朗普政府无法执行法律也根本不是真的，
because ICE officers did in fact still arrest and detain people nevertheless, right? Yeah. Okay. So the state of California initially asked the federal court for a Tiara, a temporary restraining order to have the Trump administration immediately stop what it was doing. In other words, stop calling up the National Guard. And on June 12th, the federal district judge agreed with California that this was in fact
因为事实上，ICE官员无论如何仍然逮捕和拘留了人，对吧？是的。好的。因此，加利福尼亚州最初向联邦法院请求颁布临时限制令（TRO），要求特朗普政府立即停止其正在做的事情。换句话说，就是停止调动国民警卫队。6月12日，联邦地区法官认同加利福尼亚州的观点，认为这实际上是
an illegal order and granted the temporary restraining order. The judge, that's Judge Charles Breyer, was especially worried that the Trump administration seemed to be targeting the mere act of protesting as some form of rebellion. He said, look I'm really troubled by the implication inherent in the administration's argument that protest, which is a core civil liberty protected by the implication inherent in the administration's argument that protest, which is a core civil liberty protected by the First Amendment, can justify a finding of rebellion. Or remember, this is a trial court, right?
一项非法的命令，并批准了临时限制令。这位法官——即查尔斯·布赖尔（Charles Breyer）法官——尤其担心的是，特朗普政府似乎将单纯的抗议行为定性为某种形式的叛乱。他说，听着，我真的对政府论点中所隐含的含义感到不安，即抗议这一受第一修正案保护的核心公民自由，可以成为认定发生叛乱的理由。或者记住，这是一个初审法院，对吧？
It's just the lowest level in the system. The Trump administration immediately appealed that temporary restraining order and asked the appeals court for an emergency stay or a stop of the stop, right? To actually let them keep going. Right. This is my least favorite part of our discussion. So it's the stopping of the stopping of the stopping.
它只是整个司法体系中的最低层。特朗普政府立即对该临时限制令提起了上诉，并要求上诉法院给予紧急暂缓令，或者说叫停“叫停令”，对吧？也就是实际上让他们能够继续行事。没错。这是我讨论中最不喜欢的部分。所以这就是对“叫停叫停令”的叫停。
It just spins my head every single time. I know it's very lawyerly, but the idea is like we, they wanted to keep on going. Right. Exactly. So at this stage, you know, it's not about revisiting the entire case. The appeals court just looked to see whether the administration was likely to succeed on their appeal only about the temporary injunction. In other words, they're not like saying, let's look at everything that California is arguing
每一次都把我搞得晕头转向。我知道这非常具有律师风格，但其核心意思就是我们——他们希望能够继续推进。没错。完全正确。所以在现阶段，你知道的，这并不是要重新审视整个案件。上诉法院只是审视特朗普政府是否有可能在仅关于临时禁令的上诉中胜诉。换句话说，他们并不是在说，让我们来看看加利福尼亚州在这里辩论的所有内容
here. It's just a narrow question of should there be a temporary restraining order or not. And the appeals court sided with the Trump administration, primarily because they said, in this kind of situation, we have to defer to the president. They looked at cases going back to the 19th century, and the appeals court said, look, when it comes to this kind of statute, the role of the court is not to second guess
这只是一个狭窄的问题：究竟应不应该颁布临时限制令。上诉法院站在了特朗普政府一边，主要是因为他们表示，在这种情况下，我们必须尊重总统的决定。他们回顾了可以追溯到19世纪的判例，上诉法院表示，你看，当涉及到这类法规时，法院的角色不是去事后诸葛亮般地质疑
every single thing the president does, instead, we have to be extremely deferential to the president. In other words, give Trump the benefit of the doubt. So if Trump determined that ICE was unable to execute federal immigration law under the statute, then that was enough, said the appeals court. We're not in a position to say, that doesn't seem right. Or like, sure, you arrested people so that you didn't qualify.
总统做的每一件事，相反，我们必须对总统表现出极大的尊重。换句话说，就是给予特朗普疑罪从无的宽容。因此，上诉法院认为，如果特朗普根据该法规判定ICE无法执行联邦移民法，这就足够了。我们没有立场去说“这看起来不对”，或者“没错，你们逮捕了人，所以你们不符合条件”。
Yeah. And I can understand the soundness of that logic in a general sense. Because if it's an ongoing emergency, you have to defer to the person who's thinking of it as an emergency and has to actually change the state of play on the ground. That kind of makes sense. Yeah, I mean, in the abstract, for sure, it makes sense.
是的。从一般意义上讲，我可以理解这种逻辑的合理性。因为如果这是一场正在进行的紧急情况，你必须尊重那个将之视为紧急情况、并且必须真正改变实地局势的人。这在某种程度上是讲得通的。是的，我的意思是，在抽象意义上，这当然是讲得通的。
In the abstract. That's right. We want to know. Totally. That's right. And so the court is trying to say, look, in our job, in looking at prior cases and similar types of situations,
在抽象意义上。没错。我们想要了解。完全正确。没错。因此，法院试图表达的是，看，在我们的职责范围内，通过审视以前的案例和类似类型的情况，
we have been deferential, so we have to do the same thing. So they put a stop on the stop, and the Trump administration's allowed to do what it was doing before. So now that the stop has stopped, and it can go forward under 10 USC 12406, what happens, what happened next? Well, California's lawsuit against the Trump administration actually does continue in the
我们一直都是尊重的，所以我们也必须这样做。因此，他们叫停了那个叫停令，特朗普政府被允许做它之前一直在做的事情。所以现在既然叫停令已经停止，并且可以在《美国法典》第10编第12406条下继续推进，那么接下来发生了什么？好吧，加利福尼亚州对特朗普政府的诉讼实际上仍在
federal trial court, in the federal district court. The appeals court just dealt with that emergency. So the trial court judge could decide, for instance, to issue a non-emergency, longer lasting pause on the use of federal troops. Judge Breyer said he might consider whether the use of troops violated the Posse Comitatus Act.
联邦初审法院即联邦地区法院继续进行。上诉法院只是处理了那个紧急情况。因此，初审法院法官可以决定，例如，对联邦军队的使用发布一项非紧急的、更持久的暂停令。布赖尔法官表示，他可能会考虑军队的使用是否违反了《兵团 posse comitatus 法案》。
That was one of the claims that California has made. And the appeals court did not address that issue at all in its emergency decision So there is a possibility that the federal trial court judge could say well, there's another reason I'm gonna order a pause on what the Trump administration is doing in Los Angeles And on July 15th the Pentagon announced that it would reduce the number of National Guard troops by half Those who were being posted in Los Angeles.
那是加利福尼亚州提出的诉求之一。而在其紧急决定中，上诉法院根本没有涉及这个问候。因此，联邦初审法院法官完全有可能说，好吧，还有另一个原因我要下令暂停特朗普政府在洛杉矶正在做的事。而在7月15日，五角大楼宣布将派驻洛杉矶的国民警卫队士兵人数减少一半。
So that reduces the military force down there, but there's still plenty, hundreds of troops that are still there in Los Angeles, presumably providing the muscle for ICE arrests and just basically standing around with firearms, with weapons and looking kind of scary and terrifying people. We'll be right back. So this particular case is happening in California, but you know, the ice raids and stuff are happening everywhere. Is this something that does this apply all across the United States?
这削减了那里的军事力量，但仍有大量的、数百名士兵留在洛杉矶，大概是为ICE的逮捕行动提供武力支撑，基本上就是带着枪支武器站在那里，看起来有点吓人，让人们感到恐惧。我们马上回来。所以这个特定的案件发生在加利福尼亚州，但你知道的，ICE的突袭行动到处都在发生。这是不是意味着这适用于全美各地？
Well, I think no matter what happens in this specific lawsuit, what's happening in Los Angeles actually has pretty far reaching implications for the whole country. Because let's return to that memo, that official proclamation that Trump made on June 7th. Now, the memo, if you take a closer look at it, there is no mention of Los Angeles. It simply talks about rebellions
嗯，我认为无论这个具体诉讼的结果如何，洛杉矶正在发生的事情实际上对整个国家都有着相当深远的影响。因为让我们回到那份备忘录，即特朗普在6月7日发布的官方公告。现在，这份备忘录，如果你仔细看的话，里面根本没有提到洛杉矶。它只是谈到了针对
against the authority of the United States. And Trump's call up of the National Guard is for what his memo says is any location where protests are occurring or likely to occur based on current threat assessments. Wow. So under the logic of the memorandum, troops could be sent anywhere in the United States,
美国政府权威的叛乱。而特朗普调动国民警卫队的依据，用他的备忘录的话说，是根据当前的威胁评估，抗议活动正在发生或极有可能发生的任何地点。哇。因此，按照该备忘录的逻辑，军队可以被派往美国的任何地方，
not even where there are current protests, but where the Trump administration determines that protests are likely to be happening based on their own assessment. The other part of it is there is no mention of the fact that they will send troops if there is demonstrated violence or a demonstrated threat of violence. They simply seem to be targeting protesting.
甚至都不是已经发生抗议的地方，而是特朗普政府根据其自身评估认定极有可能发生抗议的地方。另一个部分是，其中根本没有提及只有在出现暴力或有明确暴力威胁的证据时才会派遣军队。他们似乎只是在针对抗议活动本身。
So the memo really seems to be a kind of implied threat against any city where aggressive ICE enforcement is openly protested or might be protested by the community. And the memo doesn't require that there have to be reports of violence. And so that's particularly disturbing. It really seems to be targeting plain old protesting. Wow, wow.
因此，这份备忘录确实看起来像是对任何城市的某种暗示性威胁——在这些城市中，如果社区公开抗议或可能抗议激进的ICE执法行动。而且该备忘录并不要求必须有暴力报告。所以这尤其令人不安。它真的似乎在针对普普通通的抗议活动。哇，哇。
And then second, many people have seen these videos of these masked ICE officers, and sometimes in uniform, sometimes in plain clothes, seemingly rounding up everybody they see in a parking lot or a workplace based on their appearance or an accent they might have. Now they have the military behind them if the Trump administration decides that that's what they want to do.
其次，许多人看到了这些戴着面具的ICE官员的视频，有时穿着制服，有时穿着便服，仅仅根据外貌或可能带有某种口音，似乎就把停车场或工作场所里看到的每一个人都抓起来。现在，如果特朗普政府决定这就是他们想要做的，他们背后就有军队撑腰。
These are authoritarian tactics, sending the signal that no dissent will be tolerated, that any kind of dissent or protest is essentially a rebellion in the eyes of the administration. Hmm. And so if Judge Breyer were to say that this is somehow in violation of the Posse Comitatus Act, would that apply all around the country as well?
这些是独家统治术，发出的信号是任何异议都不会被容忍，任何形式的异议或抗议在政府眼中本质上都是叛乱。唔。因此，如果布赖尔法官裁定这在某种程度上违反了《兵团 posse comitatus 法案》，那也会适用于全国各地吗？
No, not necessarily, right? So it would just apply to what's happening there. But if there were another decision by the Trump administration to send another set of troops, another federalized national guard, another state, presumably that would be another kind of fact intensive inquiry of what's happening there, what kind of protest occurred there,
不，不一定，对吧？所以它只会适用于那里正在发生的事情。但如果特朗普政府做出另一次决定，派遣另一批军队、另一支联邦化国民警卫队去另一个州，那大概又将是对那里正在发生的事情、那里发生了什么样的抗议、
and what determination has the Trump administration made. And kind of based on what the Ninth Circuit has done, the appeals court, if we're giving a pretty deferential look at what the president does, seems like Trump has a pretty free hand to send troops if he wants to, which is kind of disturbing. And I think that leads to the other problem. If you think about the Posse Comitatus Act
以及特朗普政府做出了什么决定的又一次充满事实细节的调查。而且根据第九巡回上诉法院的做法，如果我们对总统的所作所为给予相当尊重的态度，看起来特朗普在想派军队时拥有相当大的自由裁量权，这有点令人不安。我认为这导致了另一个问题。如果你考虑《兵团 posse comitatus 法案》
and the exceptions, it's kind of a balancing, right, of, well, we don't want to have a standing army against civilians because soldiers have one kind of training. They're trained to defeat an enemy, right? They're not trained to respect civil liberties or to protect people, first and foremost, they're primarily there to defeat an enemy. That's the scary part of having military and that's why we don't want them in domestic
以及其中的例外情况，这其实是一种权衡，对吧？一方面，我们不希望针对平民建立常备军，因为士兵接受的是一种特定的训练。他们受过训练是为了击败敌人，对吧？他们没有接受过尊重公民自由或保护人民的训练，首要任务不是这个，他们的主要职责是击败敌人。这就是拥有军队可怕的地方，这也是为什么我们不希望他们介入国内
law enforcement. We balance that with having protection when there's an emergency within the United States. So this is not an emergency. This is not even like the Postal Service shutting down and potentially wrecking the economy in 1970. This is a completely manufactured political emergency by the Trump administration. I think the big problem, the biggest problem that we see in the memo is that if this counts as an emergency, what we see in Los Angeles, then anything can be an emergency.
执法的原因。我们将这一点与在美国境内发生紧急情况时获得保护的需求进行了权衡。所以这不是紧急情况。这甚至不像1970年邮政服务关闭并可能摧毁经济那样。这是特朗普政府完全凭空捏造的一场政治危机。我认为最大的问题，我们在备忘录中看到的最大问题是，如果这算作紧急情况——就像我们在洛杉矶看到的那样——那么任何事情都可以成为紧急情况。
Then Trump can declare any part of the United States a place where he has to send troops. And it's about to get much worse. Much worse how? This seems pretty awful already. So what much worse how? Well, it's about to get worse because, you know, a lot of attention has been paid to Trump's, I hate this, their name for it, the so-called big, beautiful bill that became law on July 4th.
那么特朗普就可以宣布美国的任何一个地方都是他必须派兵的地点。而且情况还要变得更糟。怎么个更糟法？这听起来已经够糟糕了。所以究竟还能怎么个更糟法？嗯，情况之所以要变糟，是因为（你知道的）很多注意力都集中在特朗普的——我讨厌这个称呼——他们对7月4日签署成为法律的所谓“宏大美好法案”的称呼上。
And most of the attention has been paid to the massive tax breaks for the wealthy and the big cuts to the social safety net, like cuts to Medicaid and food stamps. But it also includes, the bill also includes more than $75 billion in new funds to ICE, just ICE alone over the next four years. That includes $45 billion for immigration detention.
绝大多数注意力都集中在给富人的巨额减税以及对社会安全网的大幅削减上，比如削减医疗白卡（Medicaid）和食品券。但它也包括——该法案还包括在未来四年内专门给ICE增加超过750亿美元的新资金。
That's a quadrupling of their current budget. And more than $30 billion to expand the number of ICE officers and to fund their enforcement activities. So there's a few problems with this. First, there's very little oversight in the bill over the use of how these funds are gonna be distributed, whether it's gonna be any oversight for waste or fraud. But as a result, ICE becomes essentially
其中包括用于移民拘留的450亿美元。这相当于他们目前预算的四倍。还有超过300亿美元用于扩大ICE官员的数量并资助他们的执法活动。所以这里有几个问题。首先，该法案对这些资金将如何分配、是否存在针对浪费或欺诈的监督，几乎没有什么监管。但结果是，ICE基本上成为了
the largest law enforcement agency in the country. So you have not only the motivation here to send ICE officers everywhere with the support of the military when necessary in the eyes of the Trump administration. It's really that what we've seen in LA could become much more commonplace with ICE officers out in communities.
全国最大的执法机构。因此，你不仅有动机在特朗普政府眼中认为必要时，在军队的支持下将ICE官员派往各处。真正的情况是，我们在洛杉矶看到的一切，未来可能会变得更加司空见惯，ICE官员将深入各个社区。
And you have this massive deportation machine that once this funding is here and you have the building of even more detention facilities and the hiring of thousands of more ICE officers, that's a structure that can't easily be dismantled even after Trump is no longer president. Once you have a giant agency like this that's dedicated to immigration enforcement
而且你拥有了这样一个庞大的驱逐机器——一旦这些资金到位，建立更多的拘留设施并招募成千上万更多的ICE官员——这是一个即使在特朗普不再担任总统后也无法轻易被拆除的结构。一旦你拥有了这样一个专门致力于以这种极具侵略性的方式执行移民执法的庞大机构，
in this very aggressive way, it's hard to think of how that ever goes away. I mean, could the next person defund it all? I'd vote for that person. Well, you'd have to get Congress to decide to shrink the agency. But, you know, historical experience kind of shows that we tend not to do that when it comes to law enforcement agencies.
很难想象它会如何消散。我的意思是，下一任总统能取消它的资金吗？我会投那个人一票。嗯，你得让国会决定缩减这个机构的规模。但是，历史经验表明，当涉及到执法机构时，我们往往不会这样做。
Even if it does go away, it will take such a long time and so much effort. But in the interim, you have a lot of suffering and a lot of, you know, frankly, terrifying actions on the part of the administration. Yeah, yeah. And then just adding so much fuel to the fire, all this money that sends so many people out there
即使它真的消失了，也将需要很长的时间和巨大的努力。但在过渡期间，你会经历大量的痛苦，而且坦率地说，行政部门会采取许多令人恐惧的行动。是的，是的。这简直是在火上浇油，所有这些资金把如此多的人派出去
for potential conflict and just, or even the perception that there might be future conflict if that's the rationale that they're using to send out National Guard is really terrifying. It's just adding so much fuel to a fire. And that's not the only problem. When the appeals court decided in favor of the Trump administration, as we've already discussed, they said, look, no matter what may be really happening, we have to be deferential
引发潜在冲突，或者仅仅是让人觉得未来可能会有冲突——如果这就是他们派遣国民警卫队的理由的话——这真的非常可怕。这简直是在火上浇油。而这还不是唯一的问题。正如我们已经讨论过的，当上诉法院做出有利于特朗普政府的裁决时，他们说，看，无论实际发生的情况可能是什么，我们都必须对总统保持
to the president. This law allows the president to address emergencies. But what's noteworthy here is that the appeals court said, we presume that a president who relies on this statute is acting in what the court called good faith in the face of an emergency. But here's the problem, immigration is an important policy problem, no question, but it's not an emergency,
尊重。这项法律允许总统应对紧急情况。但这里值得注意的是，上诉法院表示，我们推定依赖该法规的总统在面对紧急情况时，是出于法院所谓的“善意”行事的。但问题就在这里，移民是一个重要的政策问题，毫无疑问，但它不是紧急情况，
nor do we have a good faith president. Absolutely true. I mean, the one countervailing force that could emerge through all this is like this sort of almost centuries long aversion to standing armies. I mean, this started in English Commonwealth. It happened. I mean, like there wasn't a British standing army in the U S for a really long time until the French and Indian war.
我们也没有一个善意的总统。绝对如此。我的意思是，可能从中涌现出的一种对抗力量，几乎是对常备军长达几个世纪的厌恶。我的意思是，这始于英国联邦。它发生了。我的意思是，在法国与印第安人战争之前，美国很长一段时间里都没有英国常备军。
And then we could handle that for almost, I don't know, maybe 10 years before we freaked the fuck out and like started a revolution because of the standing army almost as much as anything else. I mean, is there a sense that once you ratchet up this level of standing arminess in the country that that just creates such a groundswell of just like rejection of it. You know, just like that is our nature as much as almost anything else is rejecting a standing army. I don't know. I think that's right. I mean, I think like you can have a groundswell for change
然后我们勉强应付了大概，我不知道，也许10年，然后我们就彻底吓坏了，因为常备军几乎引发了一场革命，其程度不亚于其他任何原因。我的意思是，是不是有一种感觉，一旦你在国内将这种常备军的水平提升上去，就会激起一股如此强烈的、对它的拒绝浪潮？你知道的，就好像拒绝常备军和几乎其他任何事情一样，是我们天性的一部分。我不知道。我想你是对的。我的意思是，我认为你可以为某种看起来如此可怕的事情
for something that seems so scary. But I guess what's really different from between now and then is that we all need a shared reality if we're going to sort of engage and get together and say, this is not what we want. I'm not sure that we're living in that world, at least in that moment right now. Yeah, yeah. Well, this is terrifying. I'm glad we're talking about it nonetheless,
掀起一股变革的浪潮。但我想现在和过去真正不同的是，如果我们打算参与其中并聚集在一起说“这不是我们想要的”，我们需要一个共同的现实。我不确定我们是否生活在那个世界里，至少在眼下的这一刻不是。是的，是的。好吧，这太可怕了。尽管如此，我很高兴我们能讨论这个话题，
but thank you so much for talking with me. This has been really enjoyable, you know, like Thanks for coming Join us next month where we'll tackle article one which established the legislative branch of the government so much to cover The 99% invisible breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Rial and from Doomtree Records, mixed by Martín González. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Don, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman
但非常感谢你能与我交谈。这真的很愉快，你知道，就像谢谢你的到来。请加入我们下个月的节目，我们将探讨确立政府立法部门的第一条，有太多内容需要涵盖。《99%隐形》宪法解析由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔（Isabel Angel）制作，委员会剪辑，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）和杜姆特里唱片公司（Doomtree Records）提供，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）混音。《99%隐形》的执行制作人是凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Don）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg），以及我，罗曼·
Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building in beautiful Uptown Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, about flags, about music, about movies, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most these days.
马斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的上奥克兰市潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到这个节目，以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器，我们在那里就宪法、建筑、旗帜、音乐、电影等各种好东西展开有趣的讨论。这些日子我大部分时间都在那里闲逛。
You can find a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 99PI.org 上找到通往该 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。